[Musique]
Messieurs dames, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Euh, bienvenue. Nous sommes sur une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Stéphanie.
Stéphanie Fontaine, journaliste.
Antoine Champagne, journaliste
également.
et Jacques Duplé, journaliste aussi.
Allez, j'ajoute du collectif extrauros
et Antoine Champagne de Reflet de Reflet
pourinfo.
Alors, vous avez déjà reçu une première
fois pour discuter journalisme,
investigation et tout un tas de choses.
Comment ça va depuis ?
Bah, ça va pas mal. Euh quand on était
venu la dernière fois pour parler de
investigation et puis d'un projet de
documentaire justement d'investigation,
on venait parler un peu du projet.
Alors, on pouvait pas dévoiler le sujet
à l'époque sur Syeview et euh après le
passage de Syeview, ça nous a vraiment
facilité la vie. On a eu on avait un
moment, j'avais dit qu'on cherchait
éventuellement des professionnels pour
nous aider pour l'infographie, pour le
montage. Et bien, on a eu une quinzaine
de contacts de professionnels, de
sociétés qui nous ont contacté, on dit
"Bah, nous, on est prêt à vous donner un
coup de main, soit gracieusement, par
exemple, il y a un musicien qui a dit
"Moi, je fais des musiques de film, je
peux vous aider pour faire la musique ?"
Et il l'a fait. Euh on a une société qui
nous a contacté euh qui fait des
infographies, Nostromo, et ben après on
a travaillé avec eux et ça a vraiment
donné un coup de fou à notre projet
quoi.
Stéphanie,
non mais pareil depuis bah on a réussi à
fin finaliser ce projet qu'on était venu
euh on était venu en parler un petit peu
mais effectivement on pouvait pas
divulguer le sujet à ce moment-là et on
a réussi à le mener à terme donc on est
plutôt satisfait et content.
Antoine
bah super. Écoute, ça marche bien. Ça
fait 3 jours que à peu près qu'il est
c'était le 8 qu'il est en ligne. Euh,
il est en ligne sur reflet.com et sur
Alors, il est sur en ligne sur
reflet.info, sur Mediapart et sur
Caradisiac. Donc ça vous avez fait un
crowfunding pour financer tout ça ?
Alors on a fait un premier crowdfunding
pour financer ce qu'on ne savait pas
faire nous-même puisque donc comme on
fait tous les trois parties du collectif
extramuros de pigiste, on a un certain
nombre de de savoir-faire. Il y a Lizzy
qui a qui a qui était réalisatrice.
Euh mais euh voilà ce que disait
Jacques, les toutes les animations,
enfin tout sortes de de de choses,
l'étalonnage, enfin il y avait pas mal
de trucs qu'on savait pas faire et du
coup il a fallu financer ça. Donc on a
fait un premier crowdfunding qui a bien
marché, qui a permis de faire le film et
puis là on est sur un deuxième
crowdfunding sur G l'info enfin au Kepal
pour financer en fait le le travail que
nous on a fourni. euh en tant que que
journaliste puisque bon ça fait quoi ?
Quasiment 6 7 mois de de boulot
9 mois
vraiment à fond 9 mois mais à
pleintemps. Ouais.
Donc aujourd'hui on va parler euh
investigation euh la difficulté des
journalistes à investiguer. On va parler
peut-être marché public on va parler
aussi radar. On va parler aussi
peut-être pantouflage, rétro
pantouflage, pas pantouflage et on en
passer les meilleurs.
Est-ce que vous avez rencontré des
difficultés pour faire ce documentaire
mis à part financier ?
Forcément oui, on a eu pas mal de
difficultés alors financières certes
pour donc euh
merci d'avoir corrigé. Ça c'est ça c'est
ça c'est sûr mais
on a eu des difficultés parce que tout
simplement les autorités actuelles ont
refuser
euh toute question et ne nous ont jamais
répondu. Alors on le montre ça dans
notre film he radar la machine à cache,
on l'a même pas cité mais dans notre
film on le montre ça cette opacité du
ministère de l'intérieur. Et quelque
part, ça nous va bien de la montrer mais
forcément il y a quand même tout un pan
de connaissance que on ne peut avoir que
parce que bah les le pouvoir en place
veut bien répondre quand même à des
questions et à des choses on ne peut pas
le savoir si s'ils ne se mettent pas
entre guillemets à table et ils n'ont
jamais répondu à aucune de nos
questions.
Et ouais par exemple on a identifié une
centaine de marchés publics. On a
demandé la liste des marchés publics
concernant les radars automatiques au
ministère de l'intérieur. Zéro réponse.
Hier, on était au tribunal administratif
pour demander à nouveau des documents.
C'est-à-dire que la commission d'accès
au documents administratifs avait donné
un avis favorable après une première
demande de document il y a quasiment 2
ans. Et ben donc elle donne un avis
favorable. Le ministère, comme c'est
consultatif ne répond toujours pas.
Ministère de l'intérieur. Et donc il
faut aller devant le tribunal
administratif pour essayer d'obtenir les
documents. Donc là maintenant on aura la
décision dans 15 jours, 2 ans après la
première demande.
C'est même 3 ans.
Ouis 3 ans. Voilà 3 ans à première
demande. Tout est fait en fait pour
dissuader les journalistes de
travailler. Tout est fait pour all des
bâtons dans les roues. Notre générique
on dit c'est un mur.
Je vois Antoine Champagne
objecter quelque chose.
Non non je veux pas objecter. Je vais
tout à fait dans son sens. Ce que je
veux dire c'est que en fait c'est assez
amusant de voir que la sécurité routière
enfin le ministère de l'intérieur est
très pr ou ils sont très pront à
communiquer quand ça les arrange.
C'est-à-dire quand ils vont annoncer des
chiffres, une baisse du nombre de morts
sur la route et cetera. Alors ça pas de
souci, ils ouvrent toutes les portes.
Mais dès que tu commences à gratter un
petit peu en disant "Oui, bon d'accord,
mais alors est-ce que vous pourriez nous
donner effectivement une liste de
marchés publics, les des documents liés
à l'attribution de ces marchés et cetera
Alors là, il y a plus personne mais il y
a même pas une réponse. C'est même pas
non ou euh on va regarder un petit mail
ou des choses comme ça. Non.
Ah oui, faites-nous bah bien sûr,
faites-nous un mail. Maintenant, on ne
peut plus communiquer autrement que par
mail.
Euh il y a plus d'êtres humains qui
peuvent répondre. Voilà. Euh donc tu
fais tu fais tes mails et puis tu reçois
zéro réponse quoi. C'est c'est frappant
parce que tout ça ce sont des trucs
publics. Voilà, c'est pay avec nos
impôts.
Voilà, on pourrait dire ça. Oui. payer
avec nos impôts. Donc il serait normal
qu'on puisse avoir accès à des documents
produits par l'administration. Oui.
Non, mais la jurisprudence de toute
façon nous donne raison. Enfin, je veux
dire les pièces constitutives d'un
marché public dans l'ensemble. Enfin,
bien sûr, il y a des choses qui ne sont
que la jurisprudence
refuse, mais sinon euh on a euh enfin
refuse. Disons que il y a des documents,
voilà, que puisqu'il tombent sous le
coût par exemple du secret industriel,
ce genre de chos et bien on n'y a pas
accès mais la majeure partie des pièces
constitutives d'un marché public doit
être communicable à toute personne qui
en fait la demande. Donc c'est juste
hallucinant qu'il ne répondent jamais
sur ce genre de choses. Et moi, il fut
une époque parce que je demande, ça fait
quand même un moment que je demande ce
genre de chos. Il fut une époque où
j'étais quand même obligé de saisir la
commission d'accès au documents
administratifs, la CADA. Mais une fois
que j'avais cet avis positif, on me
fournissait les documents demandés.
Alors, je dis pas, ça me mettait à
l'époque la CADA était quand même moins
sollicitée, donc j'avais 6 mois dans la
vue, mais aujourd'hui, la CADA répond
déjà avec un an de même maintenant c'est
plus 6 mois, c'est 1 an. Et ensuite, il
faut donc se retrouver devant le
tribunal administratif et finalement au
bout de 3 ans, on a même pas encore les
documents. Donc forcément qui gagne
puisque
très souvent les documents qu'on finit
par obtenir ne sont plus d'actualité
donc ne valent plus vraiment la peine
d'être d'être étudié.
Monsieur Duplé, qu'est-ce qu'ils en
disent vos collègues pour enquêter ?
Est-ce que vos collègues journalistes,
ils ont le même problème ? Est-ce que
vous êtes regroupé dans un conseil
supérieur du journalisme pour dire "Bon,
écoutez, l'État maintenant ça suffit.
Est-ce que
Non, c'est j'allais dire c'est très
Est-ce que vous êtes condamné à crever
la gueule ouverte au soleil pour
attendre vos pièces ?
Bah, c'est un peu ça. Mais du coup, ça
veut dire qu'il faut trouver des
sources. Je dire, il y a deux solutions.
Soit on a les pièces euh par la CADA et
par le tribunal administratif, soit on a
des gens des sources en interne qui nous
sortent des documents. Euh par exemple
dans le film, on a un rapport de
l'inspection générale de
l'administration sur lequel on se base,
ce qui est une des pièces importantes du
film. Et ben, euh on a eu une version
bifée euh par euh grâce au tribunal
administratif ou à la cada, je sais
plus. Et voilà. Et puis on a eu la
version non expurgée par une source.
Voilà. Donc en fait l'objet donc en même
temps il y a cette opacité mais le défi
du journaliste c'est d'avoir les bonnes
sources au bon endroit qui nous
sortiront les bons documents. Après
c'est sûr on met les bâtons dans les
roues. Maintenant il y a le secret des
affaires. Voilà il y a toujours le
secret défense. Bon qui justifie par
certains côtés mais des fois ça c'est
aussi bien pratique. Voilà. Donc mais
après c'est après c'est vrai qu'il n'y a
pas tout le monde se plaint mais il y a
pas d'action concertée
des journalistes vis-à-vis de l'État
pour dire d'un côté vous vous faites
croire que il y a il y a de plus en plus
de données accessibles et d'un autre
côté vous jouez pas le jeu et vous
mettez tous les bâtons dans les roues.
Malheureusement il y a pas ça quoi.
Antoine
il y a pas plus il y a pas plus
individualistes que que les
journalistes. Euh on l'a vu parce que il
quoi c'est je je vais être très
vulgaire. C'est chacun son cuer dieu
pour tous dans la profession. Mais
ouais, c'est pas vraiment ça. C'est
c'est juste que en fait il y a pas de il
y a pas de mouvement euh de
corporatiste, si tu veux et on l'a vu
euh on avait fait un papier sur Reflet
euh quand il y a eu les convocations des
journalistes à la DGSI euh l'année
dernière euh
disclose,
l'homme France interre, enfin bon, ils
avaient ils avaient convoqué pas mal de
de personnes.
Il y a eu une manife organisée en pour
soutenir les collègues euh devant devant
la DGSI. Écoute, notre collectif, on
était quoi 5 ou 6 comme ça et après tu
avais trois quatre autres journalistes h
et pas une seule grosse rédaction
personne. Donc euh
comment comment tuexpliques ça ? Mais je
sais pas
mais ceci dit, les journalistes même qui
étaient convoqués n'avaient pas
forcément envie euh que le la la il y
ait une manifestation dans vos souv des
journaliste mais
compliqué mais je pense
c'est un principe hein. Tu voilà tu tu
soutiens tes petits camarades quand ils
sont convoqués euh indument pour faire
pression sur eux et leurs sources.
C'est ça l'objectif en fait, c'est de
d'issuader aussi les sources, même si on
peut pas s'en prendre au journalistes
avec le secret des sources et tout ça,
l'objectif à chaque fois c'est d'essayer
de dissuader les sources, de parler et
de nous transmettre des documents et
tout ça. Donc l'objectif, c'est de faire
peur. Voilà.
faire peur est-ce qu'il y a des choses à
cacher ou
je me je me je fais le temps dire
quand tu regardes ce document de de
l'IGA sur lequel on a quand même basé
une grosse partie de notre notre
documentaire donc l'ig
c'est quoi
c'est l'organe de contrôle du ministère
de l'intérieur
voilà donc ce sont des gens qui vont
enquêter sur ce qui a été fait en
interne.
Ils sont combien depuis combien créés
par qui ? Ils ont quel fonctionnement de
budget ?
Alors non, franchement on n pas on n pas
on n pas regardé tout ça.
C'est une des deux grosses organisations
qui font ce métier de contrôle interne
pour voir si tout a été fait selon les
règles.
Les grosses, ça veut dire quoi ?
Bah c'est trucs interministériels.
C'estàd que ça tu peux être l'IGA peut
être sollicité pour aller enquêter sur
n'importe quelle action de d'un
ministère en fait. Bon peu importe. Ils
ont ils font un ils font un un rapport
sur les euh les marchés publics qui ont
euh été passés pour mettre en place tout
le système en fait de traitement
automatisé des amendes. Enfin, il y a
c'est pas que les radars. Euh ils font
ce rapport et après ce rapport est
enterré, il est mis sous clé. Personne
ne peut y avoir accès, pas même les gens
qui ont été entendus par l'IGA. Voilà,
c'est sous clé.
C'est sous- clé par qui ? C'est
ministère de l'intérieur.
Pourquoi
?
Bah pourquoi ? Parce que parce que parce
que le rapport est extrêmement dur. Les
ce qui est dire
ah bah c'est très c'est très très dur
les gens qui ont
C'est dur. C'est ton interprétation ou
c'est
Non non c'est les termes qu' y a dedans.
Voilà.
C'est toujours comment les termes qu'il
y a dedans ?
Bon
non mais il est très gênant ce rapport.
Alors bien sûr que le jargon, il est
quand même il reste administratif, hein,
c'est quand même un rapport
administratif, mais dans ses
développements, voilà, en gros, il
critique de manière très négative la
mise en place, la manière dont le
système s'est mis en place avec un gros
marché unique qui a été confié à une
seule et même entreprise. Donc en
l'occurrence, c'est l'entreprise ATOS à
partir du lancement des radars
automatiques en 2003.
Ils en parlent dans ce rapport là.
Ah, ils en parlent. Ah oui, oui. Ah,
nommément. Ah oui oui oui ça il y a pas
de
l'entreprise est euh il y a très peu de
personnes effectivement nommées par leur
nom mais en revanche on les retrouve
puisque c'est leur fonction à une une
période donnée donc c'est très facile de
de retrouver euh bon il y a quand même
quelques personnes qui sont citées
nommément cité mais effectivement comme
c'est administratif c'est en général
souvent les fonctions qui sont citées
plus que les personnes, les noms des
personnes et ensuite les entreprises en
revanche sont citées. Donc là clairement
le rapport alors la mission de départ
donc c'était fin 2013, elle est elle est
elle est confiée par Manuel Vals qui
était alors ministre de l'intérieur et
il ne cible pas que les marchés publics
qui ont été confiés à Athos parce que
certes Athos avait le gros marché unique
mais il y avait quand même il y avait
enfin un gros marché pardon mais il y
avait quand même d'autres marchés
éventuellement qui étaient passés pour
accompagner et il n'était pas aussi
limitatif ce cette limitative cette
mission et pour autant L'IGA s'est
concentré sur les marchés donc confiés à
ATOS et vraiment tout le long du rapport
c'est de dire que on aurait jamais dû
confier à une SS de une société
informatique qui fait voilà qui fait des
systèmes d'information des logiciels et
cetera. On aurait jamais dû confier à
cette unique entreprise toute la gestion
du centre de Renn du centre où il y a
tous les PV qui sont traités. C'est
c'est une entreprise française. Oui.
Oui, c'est une entreprise française.
C'est déjà ça.
Et euh et c'est comme ça si vous voulez
qu'il y a eu euh qu'il y a eu des marge
indu parce qu'il il y a dû avoir
qui dit qu'il y a eu des marges indu ?
L'inspection générale de
l'administration dit qu'il a dû qu'il y
a eu des des marges qui auraient pu être
complètement évitées, des marges qui
étaient d'ailleurs confortables et qui
aurait pu être surtout évité si des
marchés si ce marché-là avait été
saucissonné et que plusieurs marchés
avaient été passés directement avec les
entreprises sous-traitantes de d'Athos.
C'est ça. C'est en fait c'est un peu
l'histoire d'un monopole de fête.
C'estàd l'histoire d'un monopole de fête
et le rapport dit un moment
l'administration
devient captive. Hm
hm. elle emploie le mot captive de
l'entreprise. Voilà. Et donc c'est là où
c'est là où ça commence à poser
problème. Sans compter effectivement ces
histoires de marge. Après nous on a des
témoins qui viennent nous raconter
comment ça se passait. Bon
avant de repasser au témoins, le le
rapport de l'UG qui l'a fait ? Vous avez
le nom des fonctionnaires qui
Oui oui bien sûr. Ouais
vous les avez rencontrés
on a essayé
et
et ils ont pas voulu parler.
Et pourquoi ? raisons personnelles, ils
étaient malades.
Non, je pense que c'est parce que voilà,
tu vois, c'est très fonctionnaire, un
peu rigide au sens où voilà je espèce de
loyauté envers le ministère. Ils sont
ils sont peut-être fait taper sur les
doigts.
Je pense pas en l'occurrence. Richard
Castera, donc c'est l'auteur he pour pas
le citer euh puisque c'est de toute
façon là pour le coup, on le cite dans
notre documentaire,
je pense tout simplement que lui dit que
le rapport il est confidentiel. pour
lui, il est confidentiel et il n'a pas
en parler. Voilà. Donc à partir du
moment où il est pas lanceur d'alerte,
et bien il se il reste dans son alors
aujourd'hui il a la retraite mais il
reste voilà tel que lui il imagine son
rôle. C'est-à-dire qu'il fait des
rapports qui doivent rester
confidentiels.
C'est le monsieur où tu vas sonner à sa
porte.
Ouais.
Oui. C'est assez drôle. On est allé ben
en fait on a on trouvait pas de
téléphone mais on a fini par trouver une
adresse et donc on s'est pointait pour
voir et voilà et donc on sonne unphone
et il y a un dialogue qui s'instaure à
l'interphone qui est assez marrant euh
voilà et on dit mais vous pouvez pas
parler mais on dit en plus le tribunal
administratif nous a communiqué une
partie du rapport. Ah non mais c'est
quand même confidentiel. C'est-à-dire
que même à partir du moment où on gagne
devant le tribunal administratif et tout
ça on dit OK c'est légitime que vous
ayez ce rapport même partiellement. Ah
non, c'est confidentiel, je vous parle
pas. Voilà. Bon,
c'est plus tellement confidentiel parce
qu'on l'a diffusé sur reflet le rapport.
Donc voilà, maintenant il est
en intégralité. En intégralité
et et c'est c'est légal.
Bah c'est un rapport fait par
l'administration. Donc
c'est confidentiel.
Confidentiel à quel titre ?
Non non concrètement là on a eu une
réponse positive quand on avait on en
avait fait la demande. Il est pas
confidentiel le rapport. Il est voilà,
il est enfin il est confidentiel. Eux
ils veulent ils voudraient en interne au
ministère de l'intérieur le garder
confidentiel mais au niveau de du droit
c'est un document fait par
l'administration et qui est communicable
à toute personne qui en fait la demande.
Alors effectivement à l'intérieur il
peut y avoir des informations qui
relèvent du secret industriel mais alors
qui c'est pas un juge qui va dire "Ah
oui alors là telle phrase effectivement
ça relève du par exemple du secret
industriel." Donc cela, c'est
l'administration qui décide euh
elle-même de ce qui relève ou pas euh du
secret industriel. Donc après, on peut
ne pas être complètement d'accord et
éventuellement s'il y a des poursuites
et bien c'est le tribunal qui devra
statuter.
Vous avez reçu des pressions ?
Non, pas vraiment non. On peut pas dire
ça. Il
il y a il y a personne euh je vais dire
de de la partie d'en face qui vous a
appelé en disant bon écoutez euh
non
non on nous a mis les bâtons dans les
roues. C'est-à-dire qu'on a essayé de
nous dissuader
et en fait comme il savait pas ce qu'on
avait euh voilà on a essayé de nous
dissuader euh par euh
en fermant les portes.
En fermant les portes.
Voilà. Maintenant bon après dans le film
on a quand même beaucoup de monde qui
vient parler. Euh
donc vous avez contacté qui euh qui
d'autre mis à part ? Vous avez contacté
un député pour aller visiter un un
centre à Renne.
Alors ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il y
avait cette opacité. On nous refuse
l'accès. On demande à aller tourner des
images au centre de Rennes. Le centre de
Renn, c'est vraiment l'usine à PV. C'est
là où sont imprimés euh les millions de
PV qui sont envoyés. Donc c'est
intéressant parce que c'est aussi
l'endroit où est concentré beaucoup
d'opérateurs privés. C'est-à-dire qu'il
y a 500 personnes qui travaillent. Sur
500, il y a que 100 fonctionnaires. Les
autres, c'est que des sous-traitants
privés. C'est ça aussi qu'on voulait
montrer. Donc refus du ministère, on
insiste refus refus refus. On s'est dit
bon tiens, on pourrait peut-être essayer
d'y aller avec un député ce qui serait
un moyen de rentrer euh bon. Et donc on
a contacté plusieurs députés et
finalement il y en a un qui a dit oui
qui est François Ruffin. Et donc on
s'est pointé avec François Ruffin au
centre de Rennes. Et donc là bah
évidemment on avait prévenu avant hein.
Donc euh il avait prévenu en disant je
vais venir éventuellement peut-être
aussi avec un sénateur et tout ça. Donc
ils étaient prévenus. On arrive, on nous
dit "Ah non, on n'est pas au courant euh
on se la joue comme ça." OK, il se
l'ajoute comme ça mais quand même la
directrice arrive, elle dit "Bon bah
vous pouvez rentrer mais les caméras
dehors." Mais en fait il y a un kiproco
assez drôle et moi j'arrive à passer
parce qu'en fait on me demande pas qui
je suis. Euh alors j'ai pas de caméra.
Moi je m'étais dit j'avais j'avais
essayé de je me suis fait tout petit.
J'ai Ouais quand même j'y arrive. Ouais.
Je suis fait tout petit et puis et puis
je colle François Ruffin. Donc en fait
on a une prendre pour son assistant et
tout. On me demande rien, on me file un
badge et je rentre avec lui. Bon voilà
et donc on a visité le truc. Bon voilà
c'était bon c'est une séquence un peu
comique mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est de montrer l'opacité c'est dès
qu'on veut arriver alors que c'est comme
il dit c'est un endroit où est dépensé
l'argent de nos impôts. Ça devrait être
ouvert aux journalistes de manière
raisonnable mais voilà. Alors que là ça
fait des années qu'il y a pas eu d'image
du centre.
Stéphanie comment vous expliquez ça ?
Non mais ça moi je trouve surtout que ça
a une résonance. ces marchés publics
effectivement c'est pas très sexy comme
sujet mais ça a une résonance par
rapport à tout ce dont ce tout ce dont
on parle qu'il faut faire des économies
et cetera. C'est-à-dire que là euh on a
euh un gros marché unique le enfin selon
le rapport de l'IGA puisqueon a le
ministère de l'intérieur n'a jamais
voulu nous répondre sur combien ce le
dernier marché confiatos le dernier gros
marché confiatos qui s'est terminé en
2016 à combien finalement il s'est
terminé hein puisque finalement on sait
au moment de la passation du marché on
sait pour quel coût on part mais en fait
il y a toujours des avenants, il y a
toujours plein de choses et donc au
cours du contrat qui a duré 4 ans et
bien il y a toujours des trucs qui se
rajoutent Et pour finir donc selon
l'IGA, il allait coûter 400 plus de 400
millions d'euros. Or euh à la suite
quand même à la suite quand même de ce
rapport de l'IGA euh et bien euh
quand même ça change euh les les la
situation change. On tronçonne ce gros
marché unique en plusieurs marchés, en
une dizaine de marchés.
C'est le marché des radars, c'est ça.
C'est pas le marché des radars, c'est le
marché de tout le système informatique
en fait.
Parce que là, j'ai une question internet
qui dit "On a un peu de mal à comprendre
le fond de l'affaire. Est-ce queon
pourrait prendre une minute pour
redéfinir le sujet ?
Oui, bien sûr. Voilà. Donc les le
système automatisé en France, bien sûr,
il y a les radars qu'on voit
physiquement, les appareils de vitesse
qu'on voit physiquement. Donc
effectivement, il y a des marchés
publics pour la fourniture de ces
radars, pour la maintenance de ces
radars, pour la vérification de ces
radars, pour l'installation de ces
radars. Alors, il y a toute une série de
marchés publics et d'ailleurs, on
l'épingle aussi dans notre film puisque
il y a une partie des marchés publics
aujourd'hui, hein, voilà, ils sont
toujours en cours, ils viennent d'être
passés entre fin 2017 qui ont été passés
sans appel à concurrence. Truc de fou
quoi. Voilà. Donc c'est comme
c'est légal ça.
Bah justement, c'est alors est-ce que
c'est légal ? En tout cas, il y a de
quoi se poser des questions et c'est
pourquoi l'association anticorruption
anticorse s'est emparée du sujet et donc
a déposé plainte pour d'élite
favoritisme dans dans un de ces
contrats. Mais le plusurs, sauf qu'il y
en a plusieurs quand même de contrats.
Donc
présemption d'innocence.
Mais oui, bien sûr, il y a présomption
d'innocence mais en tout cas, il y a
matière à s'interroger. Et puis il y a
tout le traitement automatisé de ces PV
qui arrivent, tous ces flux de en fait
c'est des flux informatiques depuis les
radars, depuis les procès, depuis les
les appareils qui permettent de dresser
les procès verbaux électroniques. Il y a
des flux qui remontent à Renes, des flux
informatiques et là-dessus on ça va
donner lieu à des procès verbaux qu'on
va imprimer et qu'on va envoyer aux
gens. Et c'est ça en fait, c'est tout ce
système informatique qui était aux mains
de la société Athos et qui était donc au
centre national de traitement de Rennes.
Et quand on parle de gros marché unique,
pourquoi ? C'est parce que au centre de
Rennes, il faut aussi de la sécurité, il
faut aussi la cantine, la restauration
pour les gens qui travaillent, il faut
aussi la décoration florale, enfin tout
un tas de choses. Et c'était confié à
une seule et même entreprise ATOS qui
est pourtant une société informatique,
donc qui n'est pas très douée en matière
de restauration ou de décoration florale
ou de ménage ou et cetera. Voilà. Et
donc depuis, je disais donc que grâce au
rapport de l'IGA, on sait que le dernier
gros marché confié à ATOS qui s'est
terminé en 2016 devait devait coûter
plus de 400 millions d'euros. Et donc à
la suite de quoi il y a une dizaine de
marchés passés, enfin ça a été tronçonné
grâce quand même au rapport de l'IGA.
Donc il y a une dizaine de marchés
passés et quand on additionne le coût
pour lequel ils ont été passés, on
arrive à 140 un peu plus de 140 millions
d'euros. la différence, elle est juste
énorme. Donc si vous voulez, ça a une
résonance pour tous les marchés publics
qui sont passés par l'État et toutes les
administrations euh aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire que il faut vraiment il y a
là, il y a un gain énorme euh financier
à mon avis parce que c'est pas là et
pourtant on en parle pas beaucoup de ces
marchés publics. Mais
c'est l'histoire du pognon de dingue
quoi.
Voilà.
C'est le titre, on a posé une question,
c'est radar de points, un pognon de
dingue pour ça. Ouais.
Et euh je vais me faire l'avocat du
diable. Hm.
Et euh donc Sarkozy veut lancer le
marché des radars, c'est ça ? Une
expérimentation avec 1000 radars.
C'est ça.
Ouais. Et euh aucune entreprise mise à
part ATOS est certifiée, c'est ça ?
Alors non, c'est plus compliqué que ça.
C'est-à-dire qu'AOS, c'est autre chose.
C'est-à-dire qu'au départ, c'est Athos
ne fournit pas les radars, ne fournit
pas les matériels. Il
c'est c'est la c'est l'entreprise Sagem
qui est devenue une filiale de Safran
qui fournit le matériel. Et là pour le
coup effectivement
dans notre film, on montre que en fait
il y avait qu'une seule une seule
entreprise à ce moment-là homologué avec
un appareil de photo numérique. Parce
que c'est ça le grand truc de du
contrôle automatisé des infractions en
2003, c'est que ce n'est possible que
avec les appareils photoques. Or à
l'époque c'est tout nouveau et donc les
radars n'étaient pas couplés avec des
appareils photonumériques. Or il ne
pouvaient enfin la plupart n'était pas
couplé avec des appareils
photonumériques. Or, le système ne peut
se mettre en place que avec l'appareil
photonumérique. Ce
ce qu'il faut comprendre, c'est que en
fait la la mise en place de ce systè
c'est un énorme système qui permet en
fait une dématérialisation de la
sanction
sur tous les trucs routiers, mais ça va
du des de des voilà de la circulation
dans une voie de bus,
le téléphone au volant et cetera. Tous
ces trucs là sont maintenant la
reconnaissance faciale dessus là. Non
non,
bah c'est pas une infraction routière
encore la reconnaissance. Mais c'est
Non non non, c'est c'est c'est juste ils
vont prendre en photo ta plaque
numérique et ta plaque de voiture et
puis et puis puis voilà, c'est après
c'est automatisé, ça va interroger le
système des des le
la base de données dans des des cartes
grises et ça va générer tout ça
automatiquement va générer une amende à
la fin. Donc c'est cette
dématérialisation qui représente un
certain nombre de de marchés confiés à
des entreprises privées. C'est une
privatisation en fait de du système de
sanction qui est qui est qui voilà qui
est qui est complètement nouveau et qui
n'existe que en France à ce à ce
niveau-là. Enfin, ce développement là,
c'est il y a que nous qui l'avons fait.
Est-ce que vous avez vu ou constater des
pantouflages de de chefs d'entreprise
entre public, privé, des choses comme ça
?
Bah c'est c'est le
c'est c'est notre ami le le gendarme qui
nous explique comment ça fonctionne en
fait.
Oui, c'est ça. On a un ancien gendarme
qui est retraité
et qui dit "Bon ben voilà, moi j'étais à
l'Agence nationale de traitement des
infractions au ministère de l'intérieur.
Donc j'arrête, je prends ma retraite de
gendarme au 15 février et au 1er mars
ben je vais travailler à la division
radar automatique chez Sagem."
On dire "Ah bon ? Ça pose pas de
problème
B non, j'ai été retraité et tout ça. Et
en fait quand il travaillait à la
division radiaut automatique, c'était
pour faire le lien avec le ministère de
l'intérieur. Donc en fait, il
reparticipa à des réunions aux mêmes
réunions du même à la même boîte voilà à
l'agence mais ce coup-là au nom de
l'entreprise alors qu'il était voilà.
Donc il y a lui et puis il raconte, il
dit "Ah mais j'étais pas le seul, il y
en avait un autre que j'ai retrouvé.
Voilà. Et donc ça c'est on voit et puis
ça va jusqu'au en haut de la liste
puisque il y a également
deux ministres donc qui ont travaillé
sur le sujet et qui se retrouvent à la
tête après des entreprises. Si c'est
peut-être des hommes performants et qui
c'est ce qu'on nous dit
qui qui vont bien gérer une entreprise
et d'ailleurs et c'est pas forcément
faux mais là n'empêche pas l'autre mais
la question la question que ça pose
c'est est-ce qu'on peut aller travailler
dans ces entreprises parce qu'il y a il
y a un comment on appelle ça un télé de
réserve un comment euh
oui normalement pour certains mais c'est
c'est normalement ça touche pas les
ministres en fait ça touche certains
fonctionnaires exacte c'est un
oui je sais plus je vois bien
c un délai avant de pouvoir repasser
dans le dans le privé sur des sujets que
tu traitais en tant que fonctionnaire.
Mais mais le ce cette problématique a
priori ne touchait pas en tout cas à
l'époque les ministres, c'est-à-dire
qu'ils avaient le droit de faire des
allées des allers-retours comme ça.
Après, c'est assez intéressant de voir
que ben finalement, si tu regardes les
choses de manière un peu pragmatique,
oui, bien sûr, même si ce sont des gens
qui ont des des qualités de chef
d'entreprise indéniables, euh forcément
le fait d'avoir travaillé sur un sujet,
d'avoir un carnet d'adresse que tu as
monté en étant
un homme politique en vue et cetera,
c'est quelque chose qui intéresse le
secteur UR privé et c'est c'est ça donne
une certaine valeur à ta candidature. On
peut pas le voilà, on peut pas le nier.
C'est c'est objectif. Voilà. Et une fois
que tu es dans ce domaine là, dans cette
entreprise, ce que tu acquères comme
compétences sur les sujets que tu
traites dans l'entreprise, et ben
finalement quand tu regardes
aujourd'hui,
ça sert aussi au nouveau poste où tu te
retrouves, tu vois. Enfin euh à chaque
fois c'est je capitalise et puis je fais
des sauts de puce comme ça. Bon euh
Stéphanie, vous avez contacté Nicolas
Sarkozy ?
Oui.
Euh euh
grand souvenir.
Et et comment ça s'est passé ?
Il était parfait, je trouve.
Et moi j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé qu'il a
été très poli
parce que moi quand il m'insulte pas du
tout.
Quand on m'appelle et que je ne connais
pas la personne en face, en général ça
se passe très très mal.
Et là ça s'est très bien passé. C'est
vrai.
Il a été il a été froid mais cordial non
?
Oui. Bah oui, il était pas content. Je
pense que on avait réussi à avoir en
fait un numéro à mon avis qui était peu
donné et il est je pense qu'il était
surpris surtout qu'on l'appelle à ce
numéro là en particulier.
Non.
Bon, c'est ce que la personne en tout
cas qui nous bon bref peu importe. Mais
en tout cas, je pense qu'il avait été
quand même il a été surpris par notre
coup de fil.
Pourquoi avoir contacté notre ancien
président ? Mais parce que tout
simplement quand ça se met en place en
fait, il y a Jacques Cher qui
effectivement qui en 2002 fait de la
sécurité routière euh son grand chantier
parmi d'autres parmi deux autres mais
voilà, il dit "On va lutter contre
l'insécurité routière". Mais Jacques
Chirac, il pensait pas spécialement aux
radars automatiques à ce moment-là. Il
dit juste on va mettre le curseur sur la
sécurité routière, on va essayer de
l'améliorer. Et euh ça c'est un peu Gill
De Robien qui nous parle à partir de là
qui nous le raconte, c'est à partir de
là bah dans les ministères, ils vont
chercher ce qu'ils vont pouvoir mettre
en place pour répondre au vœux de
Jacques Cherc. Et puis dans les tiroirs,
il traînait déjà ce système automatisé
en fait, la mise en place de ce système
automatisé qui avait été un peu
développé enfin l'idée avait été
développée sous le précédent
gouvernement donc c'est-à-dire sous
Josepin et puis personne voulait le
mettre en place parce que a priori ça
devait être quand même un peu
impopulaire et puis
et peut-être nécessaire
et peut-être nécessaire. Voilà. Bon,
toujours est-il qu'une décision
politique, la décision politique est
prise, enfin, il y a plein de petites
décisions qui sont prises au niveau de
la sécurité routière, mais le truc
emblématique
de cette époque, c'est la mise en place
des radars. Et en fait ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on sait quand on est quand on a
travaillé dessus et quelque part ils
nous l'ont confirmé quand on les a
interrogé c'est que le ça a été surtout
porté par le ministre de l'intérieur qui
était Sarkozy et surtout par son
directeur de cabinet Claude Guéan et qui
nous le raconte qui dit au départ
Gu c'est le celui qui a des tableaux
très chers et qui coûte pas ça
et Claude Gu c'est pas celui aussi qui a
dépensé 5,50 € de son compte en disant
je dis
c'est pas 5 € en disant mais C'est il y
avait pas de mouvement sur son courant.
C'est pas loin. Pas loin.
D'accord. Bon bah
ça arrive à tout le monde hein.
Oui.
Ça devait être une petite
expérimentation puis finalement ils en
ont mis 1000 radars. Donc une
expérimentation de 1000 radars.
Ça a été effectif quand même non ? Là
est-ce que la sécurité routière vous a
communiqué des chiffres en terme de
baisse de l'accidentologie routière ?
C'était vraiment pas l'axe de notre
sujet. Donc on leur a enfin on leur a
pas mais c'est des données de toute
façon là pour le coup public et c'est
très facile de les retrouver
mais voilà. fait la question c'est que
aujourd'hui on voit que dans toute
l'Europe la mortalité baisse parce que
la la v la mortalité elle est
multifactorial. Il y a que la France qui
a un système de de radar automatique
comme ça installé qui maille vraiment le
territoire et voilà. Il y a d'autres
pays où il y en a très peu et pourtant
ils ont la même pente de ba de la
sécurité routière en mortalité parce que
les voitures par exemple protègent
mieux, les routes sont mieux voilà donc
c'est multifactoriel. Donc aujourd'hui,
il y a aucune étude qui permet de dire
que les radars ont apporté plus que pour
les pays voisins, par exemple. Ça c'est
des études tout simplement qui ne sont
pas faites. Après évidemment, c'est sûr
que moins moins les gens roulent vite et
plus les gens font attention à la
vitesse, plus ça baisse le la
l'accident, la mortalité, les blessés
graves et tout ça. C'est logique. Donc
c'est sûr que les radars contribuent
mais on n'est pas capable d'évaluer la
pertinence des radars par rapport à
d'autres systèmes. Voilà. Hm.
Donc les radars feu rouges, ça ça sert
pas à grand-chose.
Alors pour le coup, les radars feu
rouges, ça c'est
ça
ça sert à respecter à faire respecter le
c'est quelque chose qui m'avait
interloqué parce que moi je tout ça je
je l'ignoraai mais en 2011, il y a une
mission parlementaire qui se met en
place sur la sécurité routière hein.
C'est vraiment le gros raout de la
sécurité routière, le dernier gros raout
de de la sur la sécurité routière qui a
eu lieu et ils ils essayent d'évaluer un
petit peu voilà la pertinence justement
du contrôle automatisé. Et donc ils
interrogent les plein d'accidentologues
et d'une manière générale les
accidentologues, ils adorent les radars.
Donc ils sont pour les radars mais les
radars de vitesse. Et là, il y a un
accidentologue qui explique que par
exemple les radar feu rouge, il est pas
complètement convaincu de la pertinence
de ses appareils parce que bah
bizarrement ça peut paraître étrange
mais en fait il y a très peu de
mortalité au carrefour qui sont donc
avec des feux rouges, avec des feux
tricol peut-être non
très certainement mais du coup il
expliquait quand même que ça lui faisait
gagner pas grand-chose parce que au lieu
d'avoir des chocs latéraux il y avait
plus de chocs frontour enfin il
expliquait qu'en fait ce serait pas mal
justement d'aller évaluer le système des
feux rouges parce que c'était il était
pas convaincu lui accidentologue lui qui
a qui est vraiment pour les radars de
vitesse, il était pas tellement
convaincu de la pertinence de ces
appareils. Mais pour autant, on a fait
des marchés publics très chers, on a
dépensé de l'argent public mais on a
jamais évalué le truc hein. Pourtant les
députés, les parlementaires de l'époque
l'avaient dit mais ça n'a jamais été
fait.
Euh quand le système des radars
automatiques a été installé, est-ce que
vous avez reçu ou vu des chiffres qui
montraient le volume d'argent récolté
par l'État ? Et si oui, quel volume le
l'état récolte ?
Bah, on a évalué nous depuis euh leur
installation presque ou en tout cas, on
a réussi à remonter euh on a réussi à
remonter à jusqu'à 2009, c'est-à-dire
savoir exactement enfin savoir
exactement à la louche combien l'État
avait dépensé dans les marchés publics,
donc c'est-à-dire dans l'installation
des radars et puis combien ça avait
récolté. Et en gros, c'est pour 1 €
dépensé, c'est 3 € récolté. C'est ce
qu'on raconte dans notre film. Donc
c'est en gros depuis 2009 7 milliards et
demi de recettes,
ce qui ce qui explique un petit peu le
fait que probablement que l'État soit si
peu regardant sur la dépense dans
l'histoire du gros marché qui attribué à
tous.
Ça pourrait rapporter plus, c'est ça.
Ben non, mais à partir du moment où tu
fais rentrer beaucoup d'argent,
après tu vois réinvestir,
dépenser, bon c'est pas grave. Tu de
toute façon tu as plein d'argent à
dépenser finalement il y a moins de
problème.
Voilà. Mais c'est surtout qu'avant de
dépenser, ce serait bien quand même de
savoir s'il y a une pertinence au niveau
de la sécurité routière. Et là, on n'est
pas du tout en train de dire que les
radars ne servent ne servent à rien.
Une pertinence, vous l'avez tous
constaté. Est-ce que vous avez tous
votre permis de conduire ici ?
Oui.
Est-ce que vous avez tous vos points ?
Quasiment. Ouais.
C'est quoi quasiment un point un point
un point près. Ouais.
D'accord. Non, moi je crois que j'ai mes
12 points.
J'en mettrai pas ma main à coupée, mais
je suis quasiment sûr.
Et et euh le fait qu'il réinstalle des
super radars tourell avec de la
technologie chinoise à l'intérieur. Vous
en parlez dans votre documentaire ou pas
?
Non, c'est pas un marché qui est enfin
c'est un marché qu'on a ciblé parce que
c'est un marché de plus de 10 ans et
donc on avait interrogé un professeur de
droit public qui trouve quand même que
c'est assez étrange 10 ans parce que ça
fait un marché très très long. Mais
il un appel à la concurrence des choses.
Oui, il y a eu quand même un appel à la
concurrence. Enfin en tout voilà pour
celui-là. Mais euh mais plus de 10 ans
euh ça paraît quand même étrange, mais
comme on avait pas d'autres bill si
j'ose dire que la longueur du marché et
qu'à partir du moment où les les
autorités où finalement on n' jamais eu
affaire aux responsables de la sécurité
routière pour leur poser des questions,
c'était on s'est dit que c'est voilà
notre documentaire était déjà assez
riche avec ce qu'on avait pour pas en
rajouter.
À titre personnel, vous avez pas
remarqué parce que bon, vous êtes plus
tout jeune tous les trois. Bon Stéphanie
un peu plus que jeune le
Ouais, toi tu es très vieux. Ça fait
longtemps qu'on te connaît. D'ailleurs,
tout le monde me demande de parler
d'Amésis là. Ils sont tous à dire
Antoine Champagne, il faut nous parler
d'Amésis.
Ouais. Non, c'est une vieille histoire
ça.
Et
vous avez tous constaté que les les
radars automatiques,
ça a calmé les gens sur la route.
Vous avez constaté aussi que il y a des
radars automatiques dans les voitures
embarquées. Ça a aussi calmé beaucoup de
personnes, non ? dans les voitures
embarquées, je sais pas en l'occurrence
mais mais dans les les radars de vitesse
en tout cas oui, on a ce sentiment là.
Oui, oui, bien sûr. Mais nous on on fait
pas un sujet personnel hein, on fait pas
voilà, on
nous c'est pas pour contre les radars,
honnêtement, c'est pas le sujet. Le
sujet du le sujet du film, c'est comment
l'argent pour faire fonctionner le
système est dépensé et on montre que
c'est une GAJ et on montre qu'il y a des
choses très bizarres qu'il y a quand
même de plaintes voilà au pénal. Donc
voilà, c'est ça le sujet. On est ni pour
ni contre les radars, c'est pas le
vraiment l'objet. Voilà, c'est pas
l'objet du film. Voilà. Après, par
rapport au juste les radars tourell, je
termine. En fait, on aura la réponse une
fois que le tribunal administratif nous
communiquera nous communiquera le marché
dans 3 ans parce que si on demande
aujourd'h
la réponse dans 3 ans.
On l'a demandé hein.
Voilà, c'est déjà en cours. Voilà.
Antoine,
non ce que je voulais dire sur les
radars après c'est tout ça est un peu
focus parce que si tu veux tu tu as bien
sûr tu as tu as les radars qui font que
les gens font un petit peu plus prudents
mais par ailleurs on commercialise
toutes sortes d'outils qui te permettent
de savoir que dans les 500 m 1 km tu vas
avoir un radar donc tu peux lever le
pied et puis une fois que tu l'as
dépassé tu as un truc qui fait bip bip
pour dire ça y est vous l'avez dépassé
vous pouvez réaccélérer
et la bî une voiture automatique
et la bî une voiture automatique de
prendre Non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que si Si on autorise la vente de
ces de ces de ces gadgets,
en même temps que on met des radars, il
y a un truc qui colle pas quoi. Si tu
voulais vraiment agir, tu dirais ben
non, c'est c'est ces trucs là sont
interdits. quand j'étais jeune,
c'est-à-dire il y a 50 et quelques
années, tu vois,
on on on récoltait des trucs qu'on
achetait à l'étranger qui était des
détecteurs de radar parce que en fait,
c'était des petits boîtiers que tu
mettais sur ton parsoleil et qui était
alimenté et en fait qui détectait les
ondes envoyées par les lunettes radar
des des policiers. Ça ça faisait bip
quand quand il y avait quelqu Alors, il
fallait freiner très vite parce que là,
tu avais vraiment pas beaucoup de temps
pour freiner. Euh, c'était complètement
interdit. Tu tu te faisais prendre avec
ça,
tu te fais prendre avec ça, tuas tu as
des ennuis. En revanche, un truc super
moderne GPS machin qui fait bip bip qui
clignote en rouge quand tu arrives dans
une zone où il y a où il y a un radar et
où en plus les gens peuvent prévenir en
appuyant sur un bouton pour dire
attention j'ai croisé un radar à cet
endroit-là. Ça c'est autorisé
puis pour longtemps.
Si si si il y a eu un mouvement Si si,
il y a eu un mouvement pour essayer de
les interdire. Les gars ont gueulé, ils
ont fait jouer leur communauté. Euh
voilà, tout le monde s'est énervé et
finalement le gouvernement a mis ça sous
le sous le machin
qui s'occupe du du paramétrage de ces
fameux radars. Est-ce que vous avez
rencontré des ingénieurs en optronique
pour mettre le le nez dedans ? Est-ce
que comment ils sont certifiés ?
Est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est comme
les balances au marché ? Vous savez vos
balances au marché doivent être certifié
?
Bon, je pose la question, je connais
déjà la réponse. J'ai des copains qui
sont ingénieurs en optronique et un jour
ils m'ont dit "Si tu veux, on peut faire
cramer tous les radars de France
embarquer d'un coup parce qu'ils sont
tous en maintenance." Donc il y a juste
à faire péter le truc et là il y aura
plus de trêve de plaisanterie.
Ben en fait oui et c'est certifié. Euh
après nous c'est pas non plus notre
sujet. La certification elle est bonne.
Les gens ils sont compétents. On s'est
certifié aujourd'hui des optiques sur
des mesurer la vitesse et voilà. Donc
mais évidemment les radars sont
certifiés pour donner une vitesse avec
une marge d'erreur suffisamment
raisonnable pour pas pénaliser les gens
en théorie. Voilà.
Donc vous, c'est simplement l'argent des
marchés publics qui vous a intéressé.
Voilà, c'est ce que quand tu as quand tu
as Emmanuel Macron qui te dit voilà
c'est tout ça nous coûte un pognon de
dingue en parlant des pauvres à qui on
donne quelques miettes mais voilà quand
on te dit il faut arrêter un système par
répartition parce que tout ça
il y a un truc qui colle pas encore une
fois il y a un double discour on ne
regarde pas comment on dépense l'argent
on fait on fait pas attention à ce qu'on
fait et et parfois ça ça va quand même
assez C'est loin. Il y a des trucs qui
sont c'est qui sont emblématiques. C'est
c'est choquant. C'est surtout
emblématique. Par exemple, on a on a
trouvé dans ce rapport que donc voilà,
tu vois, Athos est payé pour euh payer
le loyer des bâtiments à Rennes. Voilà,
c'est eux qui payent le loyer.
Enfin, qui payait qui payait pay non.
une qui payait qui payait, on parle au
passé euh il payait le loyer de du
bâtiment dans le dans lequel est
installé tout le système à Renn euh au
bailleur parat qui s'en occup
c'était pas l'État qui payait le
propriétaire des des locaux, c'était
ATOS pour payer les loyers
pour virer les loyers
pour pour faire le virement trois fois
par an 300000 €
300000 € pour appuyer sur un bouton
trois fois par an, tu peux te dire que
ouais, ça coûte un pognon de dingue.
300000 € je pense que tu peux faire tu
peux faire tu peux faire beaucoup pour
des SDF, tu peux faire beaucoup pour
plein de gens, tu vois. Donc pour
l'hôpital, voilà euh des gens qui ont
vraiment besoin de de fonds,
sachant sachant qu'ils étaient payés,
sachant qu'Ahos était rétribué par
l'État pour piloter le projet. C'estàd
comme il gérait plein de sous-traitants,
il recevait 10 millions d'euros sur la
durée du marché pour faire le lien,
assurer le secrétariat, pilotage avec
les autres sous-traitants et coordonné.
Donc 100 millions, c'est quand même pas
neutre, hein. C'est quand même bon, même
s'il y a bon beaucoup de boulot, OK, ils
reçoivent 100 millions. Mais ce qu'on
montre aussi, c'est que derrière tous
les sous-traitants, ils prenaient en
plus une marge jusqu'à 22 %. Et par
exemple, il y a un voilà dans le rapport
et on a interrogé l'ancien directeur de
Doca Post qui est une fiade de la poste
qu'on voit les amendes. Et ben ils
disent bah voilà vos euh est-ce que vous
étiez au courant que Athos sur votre
contrat il se prenait en plus 22 % de
marge pour ne voilà alors qu'ils étaient
déjà payés pour piloter le projet et
faire le lien avec Doc Post. Donc il ce
qu'on montre c'est comment il se
payaient deux fois. Il se payait par le
pilotage et il se payent en plus en
prenant une marge sur le travail des
sous-traitants.
Ça c'est intéressant de voir la réaction
de l'ancien patron de Docapos quand il
apprend quand on l'interroge.
Ça ressemble à quoi sans faire de
spoilers ? Bah il a un petit temps comme
ça, puis après il se marre et puis il
dit euh "Ah ben, ils sont bien
débrouillés quand même."
Ouais.
Stéphanie, les marchés public c'est
quand même énorme. Euh
est-ce que vous avez euh votre
profession qui a décidé de vous
contacter pour dire voilà, mis à part
Média Parter
en disant voilà mais est-ce que vous
avez d'autres dossiers là-dessus ?
Est-ce que vous avez d'autres marchés
publics qui ont été passés du même genre
ou
non ? Alors les professions pour
l'instant non, elle nous a pas elle ne
nous a pas contacté spécialement mais
sur les marchés publics, oui, je pense
qu'il y a vraiment un axe là d'enquête
et effectivement moi je à chaque fois
qu'on met le doigt sur un marché public
il y a des questions à se poser. Je ne
dis pas qu'à chaque fois il y a des
dysfonctionnements et des malversation
on est au direct pas diffation pas tout
ça. Non mais bien sûr mais c'est
vraiment les marchés là on en a on en on
parle effectivement du marché des
voitures radar parce que comme c'est en
train d'être privatisé là encore
on disait tout à l'heure c'est forcément
très efficace pour l'instant les
voitures radars privatisées de ce qu'on
en sait parce que pareil il a une telle
opacité qu'en fait on ne sait pas
exactement combien il y a de PV qui sont
qui sont dressés via ces voitures.
Vitesse et stationnement.
Non là c'est que vitesse pour le coup
c'est quand même très séparé. Donc là,
on parle que des voitures radar vitesse,
donc qui prennent les excès de vitesse
et qui sont confiées à des chauffeurs
issus du privé. C'est ça, ça commence à
se mettre en place en France.
Ils sont assermentés.
Ah non, ils sont pas sermentés, c'est
des salariés du privé. Point. Et euh et
donc c'est une entreprise privée qui les
gère et euh donc qui remplace les
gendarmes ou les policiers qui qui sont
à bord. Et il y en a toujours hein des
voitures radars avec des policiers et
des gendarmes mais là c'est en train de
d'être remplacé. Et la sécurité
ce qui permet de réaffecter les
gendarmes et les policiers. La sécurité
routière nous explique ça, c'est que de
toute façon ces voitures radar étaient
étaient au garage parce que finalement
on avait pas la main d'œuvre pour les
pour les faire rouler. Mais encore une
fois, pourquoi on en a acheté si on
était pas capable de les utiliser ?
Enfin, je
conforme pas plus de policiers. Non mais
non mais voilà, on peut on peut prendre
voilà, je vois pas pourquoi tout d'un
coup il faudrait privatiser le cette
mission à partir du moment où on a
acheté quelque chose et qu'on s'est
rendu compte après qu'on en avait trop
acheté parce que c'est pareil, on aurait
pu en acheter moins. Enfin,
pourquoi on a trop acheté ?
Bah alors ça, mais c'est pour ça c'est
des questions qu'on qu'on est en droit
de se poser, je trouve.
Est-ce que l'administration
l'administration euh a une conduite
introspective ? Est-ce que vous avez
regardé un petit peu ce qui se passait
dans les administrations ? S'il y a des
gens qui ont été sanctionnés parce que
par exemple ils ont acheté trop de typex
et trop de stylo euh est-ce que les
sanctions sont très faibles par rapport
à ça.
Il y a même pas de il y a même pas de
d'introspection réelle par exemple.
Enfin, tu vois, on parle des histoires
de voit de de radar, de voiture radar et
cetera parce que c'est par cet angle là
qu'on a pris le sujet des marchés
publics. Mais tu Ça pourrait être ça
pourrait être l'ouvre.
Ça pourrait être scandale.
Ben c'est le le
traitement informatique des des la paye
des des militaires. Bon
c'est le truc qui plantait à chaque
fois.
Voilà, ça a planté milliards de fois. Ça
a coûté des millions et des millions
pour rien. Ça marche pas. Il y a des
militaires qui sont pas payés. Enfin
bon,
on est obligé de rendre l'argent.
Il y en a qui on a demandé de rendre
l'argent. Enfin bon, c'est c'est c'est
n'importe quoi. Mais mais ça c'est il y
a pas que ça. Tu peux prendre un autre,
c'est le le marché open bar Microsoft au
ministère de la défense. Enfin, tu as
toutes sortes de trucs comme ça dont
dont on pourrait parler aussi quoi. Mais
il y a pas mais quelle est
l'introspection ? À quel moment le le
gouvernement se dit "Bon ben OK, on a
fait une erreur euh voilà, on arrête
avant que ce soit trop tard." Il y a
c'est des comportements euh enfin les
psy ont analysé ça depuis très
longtemps. C'est quand tu fais des
conneries, il y a un moment où
normalement tu devrais t'arrêter mais
comme tu veux pas perdre la face, tu
continues et tu fonces dans le mur en
fait. Euh bon ben voilà. Alors moi j'ai
un
J'espère qu'on peut pas appliquer ça à
la finance internationale parce que
sinon on est dans la merde. Bah eux de
toute façon en plus ils ont une carte
joker. que eux ça va parce que même même
quand ils rentrent dans dans le mur
après c'est le seul secteur de
l'économie
où c'est nous qui payons tout le temps
non c'est le seul secteur de l'économie
où personne ne fait faillite de temps en
temps une banque parce que il faut faire
un exemple mais c'est tout mais c'est
c'est un secteur qui quand il a fait
toutes les conneries possibles et
imaginables, il s'est mis dans une
situation de faillite se retourne vers
le gouvernement et dit "Bonjour il faut
nous donner des sous et là ils sortent
leur carte joker Ils disent risque
systémique, tout va s'écrouler. On se
doit de l'argent les uns entre les
autres. Donc s'il y en a une qui tombe
et fait domino et euh tout le monde et
donc il y a plus de banque, il y a plus
d'argent et voilà après révolution dans
la rue et cetera. Risque systémique.
Avant ça c'est on vous perra plus le
financement de vos campagnes.
Ouais. Alors ça, je sais pas si c'est si
c'est ça, mais en revanche le coût de
risque systémique c'est à chaque fois à
chaque fois ils sont on leur donne de
l'argent pour qu'ils fassent pas
faillite.
Est-ce que vous avez rencontré par
exemple des pays par exemple nordiques ?
Est-ce que vous avez étudié la conduite
introspective des pays nordiques sur la
gestion des fonds publics ? Est-ce que
la France est inspirée des fonds des de
l'audit des fonds publics des pays
nordiques ?
On n'est pas allé regarder. Non non
non non. Par contre, ce qui est
intéressant, c'est qu'on a un ancien
procureur de la Cour des comptes
euh qui vient nous raconter en fait
comment il manque de moyens. C'estàdire
que des fois, c'est pas l'absence de
volonté de l'État de contrôler. La Cour
des comptes, ils cherchent à faire leur
boulot. Et le procureur dit "Moi,
j'avais demandé qu'on aille inspecter
ces marchés." Et ben non, pour les
radars, on s'est contenté, la Cour des
comptes s'est contenté d'examiner
uniquement les documents qu'on lui
donnait, des comptes, voilà, et de lire
les comptes et dire "Ouais, c'est bon,
les chiffres sont la bonne case, mais
ils sont pas allés voir ce qu'il y avait
derrière." et lui il l'avait demandé
comme procureur et ça lui a été refusé
par manque de fonctionnaires. Donc c'est
aussi ça le problème. Et après sinon
j'ai un exemple où l'État il a eu un peu
d'introspection, ils ont changé leur
fusil d'épaule. C'est la PNIGE, la
plateforme nationale des interceptions
judiciaires. Et en fait, ils ont en fait
c'était en interne, donc les écoutes
téléphoniques, ça a été externalisé et
finalement ils sont aperçus que ça
merdait tellement et voilà et ben qu'ils
sont en train de ils sont actuellement
en train de réinternaliser ils
embauchent des ingénieurs télécom pour
reprendre le système à leur compte,
reprendre les serveurs, reprendre un peu
tout parce que ils avaient externalisé
au privés et ils sont dit que c'était
pas top et ils ont eu plein de problèmes
et plein de dysfonctionnement et avec la
lutte anti là, ils ont pas plaisanté
parce que comme il y avait la lutte
antiterroriste aussi derrière
Là, à un moment, ils se sont dit, il est
pas question de sa merde. Et là, ils ont
fait de l'introspection et ils ont
décidé de renforcer et de de créer des
postes et de voilà.
Mais de toute façon, sur notre sujet
aussi quelque part hein, le rapport de
l'IGA, les révélations de la presse, la
plainte d'anticorps font que quand même
il y a eu une évolution. Donc quelque
part, il y a il y a des choses quand
même positives. C'est-à-dire que quand
même ce gros marché dont on a parlé tout
à l'heure global n'existe plus. Donc euh
quelque part ça s'est assaigni, mais ça
s'est assaigni euh voilà sur un sur un
pan et on voit bien que il faudrait que
ça s'assaignissent euh sur d'autres ps.
Voilà. Mais il y a eu quand même et puis
il y a le préfet qui a été quand même
euh voilà qui a été débarqué et qui a eu
quand même débarqué.
Pourquoi il a été débarqué ?
Oui, c'est vrai que c'est pas forcément
pour les histoires de marché public
alors que ça mériterait mais c'est parce
que effectivement il avait fait payer
ses propres PV par son administration.
Oh bah alors ? Bah alors ouais
Antoine
bah rien. Le le déroulement de du
documentaire c'était long. Vous avez
fait comment ? Vous avez été obligé
d'incarner votre documentaire ? Comment
ça se passe
? Bah c'est c'est un alors pour pour des
gens qui sont plutôt pressécrites comme
nous à la base
et heureusement il y avait Litreux avec
nous.
Heureusement Heureusement il y avait
Lisitreux avec nous. Euh c'est euh c'est
vrai que un documentaire c'est euh très
long en fait à faire. Voilà. Euh mais
c'est très lourd, c'est très long mais
voilà, c'est passionnant. C'est aussi
une œuvre de salubrité publique, non ?
Ah oui oui, bien sûr. Non mais
c'est gratifiant. C'est gratifiant
d'être journaliste au 21e siècle.
Bah ça dépend de pourquoi tu fais ce
métier. Mais ouais ouais bien sûr. Moi
je pense que c'est c'est gratifieux. Ce
qui ce qui est sympa, c'est quand tu as
des retours positifs comme on a là en ce
moment où tu as des gens partout sur
Twitter qui disent "Merci, bravo,
génial" et cetera. Là, tu te dis que tu
as pas bossé pour rien. C'est tuas tuas
voilà, tuas tu as aidé les gens à
comprendre une problématique, tu as mis
en lumière un truc que voilà personne ne
mettait vraiment en lumière. Donc c'est
sympa. Après, c'est gratifiant, mais le
problème le problème qui se pose, c'est
celui du modèle économique. On voit
qu'il y a de moins en moins de cases
d'investigation à la télévision
et c'est jusqu'à présent la télé qui
finançait l'investigation. Un
documentaire, faut savoir que ça coûte
en moyenne 80000 € voire plus. Et donc,
c'était la télé qui donnait, qui avait
les moyens de payer des gens pendant
entre public privé la télé
les deux au départ les deux. Alors
maintenant bah il y a plus que le public
qui en fait et puis parce que après tous
les trucs de la TNT où ils appellent
enquête je sais pas quoi, enquête
d'action, enquête de je sais pas quoi,
il y a tout sauf de l'enquête. Voilà,
donc ça faut oublier. Ensuite bah Canal
Plus Bolloré a supprimé l'investigation.
C'est quoi ? Je On regarde pas la TNT.
Voilà. Ouais, on regarde voilà, c'est
ça. On regarde pas la TNT façon voilà.
Donc Canal, il y a plus d'investigation.
Bon, il y a Cach Investigation qui est
la tête d'ou de l'investigation mais
entre guillemets, moi je dis c'est aussi
le cash misère de l'investigation. Euh
voilà.
Cach misère.
Bah parce qu'il y a de moins en moins
des des missions d'investigation. Donc
c'est-à-dire que eux ils font du super
boulot. Euh voilà. Après, il y a pièce à
conviction sur France 3 qui fait aussi
du super boulot. Mais enfin
pression quand même. Nous on l'a
ressenti, il y a une pression qui se met
sur la télé puisque les cases en fait
son sont effectivement réduites et donc
il y a tout d'un coup une pression. Et
par exemple sur ce sujet-là
effectivement tout d'un coup la télé
elle dit "Ah oui mais non c'est pas
concernant,
c'est pas sexy, il y a pas assez séqué
sexy, il y a pas assez de séquence."
Donc du coup on le traite pas ce
sujet-là. Or quand même les radars
automatiques, on en parle beaucoup et ça
fait à mon avis un
mec avec des gilets jaunes dans la rue
qui gueulent contre les histoires de
radar et tout ça.
Bah je trouve que effectivement ça
mérite puisqu'on le on on le traite
toujours de ce de du point de vue de la
sécurité routière. C'est forcément
intéressant et important. Je ne dis pas
le contraire, mais pour le coup, c'est
aussi énormément euh un finance, bah
c'est un financement public avec
d'énormes marchés publics et on le
montre dans notre documentaire avec
quand même des questions à se poser avec
effectivement cette histoire de
pantouflage, avec les cette histoire de
décision politique qui tout d'un coup
dit "Ah oui, il y a une urgence" et qui
en fait finalement bah elle passe outre
la concurrence la mise en en concurrence
des entreprises et tout ça. Ça
ça a une résonance vraiment aujourd'hui
où on narrête pas de nous dire que tout
coûte un pognon de dingue et qu'il faut
se serrer toujours la ceinture. Quelque
part, c'est c'est je trouve important et
d'intérêt public que de parler de ce
genre de sujet. Or, la télé n'est pas n
veut pas traiter de ce genre de sujet.
C'est pourquoi on l'a fait de manière
indépendante. Il
il y a un autre b quoi une autre un
autre une autre problématique, c'est
celle de la crainte des procès. Moi par
exemple là, j'avais j'avais un
documentaire qui concerne l'industrie
pharmaceutique.
Donc on avait passé un premier barrage
sur une chaîne publique, ils étaient
intéressés et finalement ils nous ont
dit non. Ils ont dit on craint les
procès des labbaos derrière alors qu'on
venait déjà c'estàd j'ai déjà des
documents, j'ai déjà des témoins, j'ai
déjà des personnages et là on pouvait
l'incarner. Enfin, ça rentrait bien
voilà. Et ben, on nous a dit, ça
rentrait bien dans les critères de
sélection de la télé. Et ben, on nous a
dit non parce qu'on craint euh les
procès,
c'est qui on
Ouais, une une des chaînes du groupe
France Télé, voilà, qui nous dit on
craint des procès donc on va pas le
faire. Voilà, il dit ça la boîte de
production. Et donc la question c'est à
ce moment-là, on le fait comment ?
C'estàd on peut le faire que par le
crowfunding et donc à et voilà. Et on
voit aujourd'hui dans notre modèle que
on j'allais dire on n'arrive pas là
encore on n' toujours pas boucler
quement notre budget. Voilà, il nous
manque il nous manque il nous il nous
manque toujours 30000 € pour arriver à
se donner quelque chose alors qu'on a
travaillé plus de 7 mois là-dessus.
Antoine les procès dans le milieu du
journalisme c'est c'est de plus en plus
d'actualité. C'est c'est ça devient
vraiment moyen de pression dissuadé.
Ouais évidemment. Évidemment, pour mais
pour une raison simple, c'est que en
fait les boîtes ou l'État à partir du
moment où il décide d'engager une
procédure
euh c'est pas grave. C'est il y a il y a
un budget pour ça tous les ans. Tu vois
le service juridique c'est des centaines
de milliers d'euros. En face tu as quoi
? Tu as bah soit un journal qui est en
difficulté de toute façon parce que les
journaux aujourd'hui voilà euh donc il y
a pas non plus des 100 à dépenser
là-dessus. Euh tu as euh des
journalistes qui euh ne sont ne roulent
pas sur l'ord de toute façon.
Euh dénutri
dénutri euh
si vous pouvez vous envoyer un jambon ou
un truc pour qu'on puisse manger. Non
mais voilà. Donc évidemment,
c'est pour nous c'est un problème quand
il y a quand il y a un procès et tu peux
pas faire face à 50 procès. Donc tu vois
bien que les procès deviennent ce qu'on
appelle des procès billons. Et s'il y
avait que ça en fait, tu as des des des
entreprises qui vont tout simplement
couper leur budget pub au canard. Donc
les les journaux vont pas vouloir
traiter d'un sujet où derrière il y a un
risque pour que la pub s'arrête. L'IB a
eu ce problème avec LVMH.
Pas mal de journaux ont eu ce problème
avec Volkswagen au moment où ils ont
truqué les tests machin où où les
marques disent "On arrête on arrête nos
nos nos budgets pub chez vous." Donc
évidemment quand tu as quelques
centaines de milliers d'euros qui qui
partent à la trappe tu réfléchis à deux
fois. Après, quand tu veux refaire un
sujet euh sur ces gens-là,
vous avez déjà été condamné trois ?
Est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des procès
sur des affaires ? Ah oui oui. Bah moi
j'ai oui moi j'ai eu des plusieurs
procès. Un où j'ai été condamné euh
bah une une critique d'un livre
interview d'un auteur. Donc c'était même
pas de l'investigation mais voilà et
donc j'ai interviewé l'auteur d'un livre
voilà sur une histoire de barbouserie et
voilà et donc la critique de la
chronique quoi. Voilà ça une chronique
du livre voilà donc une critique du
livre et puis après j'en ai eu d'autres
bah où j'ai gagné j'en ai encore un en
cours. Euh voilà. Ouais on a
Antoine.
Non moi j'ai une fois un procès pour
on m'accusait de piratage informatique.
Voilà. Euh
c'était pas toi
hein. Si c'était un peu moi. Euh c'était
un peu moi. Mais d'ailleurs, je m'en
cachais pas. J'ai toujours dit que en
fait c'est une enfin c'est c'est comme
ça depuis le début. J'ai toujours dit
que j'assumais mes propos et mes écrits
et donc c'est moi qui viendrai devant un
tribunal si jamais. Et c'est arrivé.
Voilà. Donc j'ai perdu en première
instance. Le parquet a fait appel. C'est
très très spécial. Euh le parquet a fait
appel pour demander ma relaxe et que
j'ai obtenu en 2e instance. Donc
aujourd'hui, tu as pas mal de gens qui
disent "Oui, mais lui il a été condamné
pour piratage informatique". C'est parce
qu'en fait il regarde pas. Mais j'ai été
relaxé en appel et c'est définitif. Donc
Stéphanie,
moi j'ai été aussi condamné et relaxé.
J'ai eu les deux.
Condamné à quoi ?
À un neurosymbolique. Diffamation, un
neurosymbolique. Donc voilà, il y a les
deux. Et c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose en fait, moi je me souviens que la
première fois quand ça m'est arrivé
enfin quand j'ai su qu'il y avait une
procédure, je dire alors là moi j'avais
en tête que quand même c'était parce
qu'on avait écrit n'importe quoi ou j'en
sais rien. Je me disais bah ils peuvent
toujours venir et en fait on est
vraiment c'est vraiment voilà on se fait
un euros symbolique c'est que forcément
il y avait on était pas complètement
entre guillemets vraiment enfin on était
bien sûr
fallait marquer le coup
voilà fallait marquer le coup mais je
veux dire voilà c'est vraiment on est
sur le fils du rasoir c'est dans
l'expression en fait est-ce qu'on a
est-ce qu'on a pas manqué de prudence
par rapport à la base factuelle qu'on
avait et cetera c'està-dire que jamais
il est dit que on a écrit n'importe quoi
et qu'on a et que vraiment c'est ça
relève enfin voilà que c'est la relève
du mond mensonge par exemple à aucun
moment mais c'est
parce qu'on écrit pas dans valeur
actuelle.
Voilà sans doute. Je sais pas pourquoi.
Valeur actuelle c'est quoi ?
Bon c'est un journal où ils écrivent
plein de conneries.
Bon
tu as des preuves ?
Oui.
Et ouais
les preuves.
Oui oui.
Dernière question du moin on va
commencer à à poser une question sur
l'état de la presse française la
concentration de la presse. Vous voulez
en mettre une petite couche ? Que dire ?
À part que c'est à part que c'est un
problème, j'allais dire aujourd'hui
voilà, c'est-à-dire que la dépendance
par rapport à des milliardaires
propriétaires, la dépendance par rapport
à la pub, bon ben voilà, on sait tout le
monde sait que c'est un problème. Euh
voilà, donc après justement il faut
promouvoir des modèles indépendants.
Mais des modèles indépendants en même
temps, il faut qu'ils aient les moyens
parce que l'autre fois refla un article
en disant c'est quoi la presse
indépendante ?
Parce qu'il y a un syndicat de la presse
en ligne indépendante et tout ce qu'on
veut. Bon euh très bien. Mais la
question c'est quoi aujourd'hui euh de
dire presse indépendante ? Et moi je dis
aussi qu'un des problèmes, c'est que on
est aussi indépendant si on a les moyens
de traiter ces sujets parce qu'il suffit
pas de pas avoir d'actionnaire, il
suffit pas de pas aller merger chez
Google ou chez Facebook. Euh voilà donc
euh mais en même temps, ça veut dire
qu'il faut avoir une communauté, des
lecteurs, des euh téléspectateurs, des
voilà qui euh financent cette presse et
qui s'abonne. Et pour l'instant, bon ben
j'allais dire il y en a deux. Bah, il y
a l'ancien modèle avec le canard qui
fonctionne et eux, ils ont un trésor de
guerre incroyable et eux
incroyable.
Bon, incroyable. Je crois qu'ils peuvent
distribuer gratuitement en payant les
salaires et en offrant le journal au
lecteur pendant 1 an.
2 ans
2 ans. Voilà. Donc, c'estàd qu'ils ont
qu'ils sont là depuis 1914 que à chaque
fois qu'ils font des bénéfices, ils les
ils les mettent réserve.
Il y a pas d'impôt sur les bénéfices
pour la presse.
Si bien sûr,
mais même avec ça. Voilà.
Même avec ça.
Et voilà. Puis il y a Miapart voilà avec
leur à peu près maintenant il doit être
à peu près à plus de 150000 abonnés et
qui arrivent à super à faire du super
boulot. Bah d'ailleurs on bosse aussi
pour eux. Voilà. Et euh
mais il y a plein d'autres modèles quand
même qui se développent hein. Médiacité
les jours, les jours. Voilà. Mais bon
euh voilà mais c'est mais c'est
compliqué, c'est toujours très très
fragile. Et on voit par exemple même
Médiap qui diffusent notre documentaire,
leur participation financière n'a rien à
voir avec le coût réel du film.
Combien ils ont mis ?
Non mais ça on peut pas rentrer
exactement là-dedans, mais c'est pas
grandchose. Combien ils ont mis ?
Voilà. Voilà. Mais comme car comme non
mais non mais quoi ? Mais nous on
publiera nos dépenses. Mais c'est dit
voilà mais faudra faut leur demander.
Mais pareil Caradisiac aussi bon ils ont
fait des efforts alors que c'est un site
qui est quand même qui est gratuit.
Enfin voilà, ils ont aussi fait des
efforts pour contribuer au pour payer
pour pour diffuser. Ils ont mis combien
Mia part ?
Ils ont mis quelques sous mais c'est pas
effectivement ça a rien à voir avec ce
que pourrait mettre un une boîte de prod
ou payée par une télé et cetera. C'est
c'est on est dans des dans des
proportions qui sont bien moindres.
Enfin, c'est c'est
ils étaient pas producteurs. Donc à
partir du moment voilà,
diffuseurs, si tu veux du truc, il ils
mettent un peu d'argent pour pouvoir
diffuser le le documentaire.
Voilà. Bon euh mais c'est sûr que c'est
c'est pas que avec ça queon peut faire
qu'on peut faire un documentaire, ça
c'est sûr.
Vous êtes condamné à crever en fait.
Ah non, parce qu'on compte aussi sur la
communauté.
Stéphanie. Stéphanie.
Non, mais c'est un problème aujourd'hui.
D'une manière générale, la presse et la
presse audiovisuelle aussi. Et je pense
que quelque part euh le fait que les
cases se referment là sur
l'investigation euh à la télé, à mon
avis, ça vient de ça parce que ça coûte
très cher. Effectivement, nous on est
parti sur ce projet-là, on s'est dit on
a déjà enfin on avait déjà beaucoup de
l'enquête était déjà bien avancée. On
s'est dit "On va ça va aller vite mais
en fait non, ça ne va pas vite parce que
en vidéo c'est très lourd. Euh voilà et
donc tout d'un coup, on s'est rendu
compte que c'était très long et donc
forcément comme c'est long, ça coûte
cher. En plus, on a vraiment voulu faire
quelque chose de très bien. On a euh on
a des animations euh pour parce qu'on
savait que le sujet était un peu aride,
un peu compliqué et donc on voulait que
les gens comprennent bien notre sujet.
Donc on a on a un budget animation euh
forcément euh et on a affaire à vraiment
une société la Nostromo qui a vraiment
fait un travail formidable et qui en
plus l'a fait mais vraiment à moindre
coût quoi. Vraiment parce que elle était
solidaire de notre projet. Euh vraiment
on a eu beaucoup de chance post la
post-production pareil enfin vraiment on
a eu affaire euh donc euh
ce qui nous ont demandé était symbolique
alors que donc euh
donc qui s'appelle les brétillards hein,
je préfère le dire euh voilà Wild Times
Record et c'est eux qu'on fait par
exemple qu'on la postpro du film Demain.
Bon voilà, c'est vraiment des super
pros. et Cyril, il en parlait tout à
l'heure, qui nous a effectivement fourni
toute la musique du film ou presque,
enfin pas complètement une grosse
partie, mais enfin vraiment on a eu sur
cette affaire là beaucoup de solidarité,
heureusement parce que sinon de toute
façon, on narrivait même pas à le mettre
sur pied. C'est-à-dire que même nous en
roiant sur nos salaires, de toute façon,
si c'est tous ces gens là que je viens
de citer n'avaient pas finalement fait
preuve aussi de faire un effort, de
toute façon, on pouvait pas non plus
faire ce film parce que
Comment vous vivez vous trois ? C'est
quoi vos rentrées d'argent ? Vous
on fait la manche tous les matins.
Non mais c'est les piches, c'estàdire
mais oui, c'est moi en bas de chez toi,
tu sais pour rester propre et
indépendant.
C'est dire que c'est
tu peux venir prendre une douche à la
maison quand tu veux.
C'est sympa.
C'estàd que en plus du film, fallait
qu'on essayait qu'on travaille à côté.
avant un peu pendant et voilà. Mais mais
c'est clair
puis c'est un projet qui se prévoit
quand même. Je veux dire, on est voilà
qu'on a
Vous arrivez à dormir ?
Oui.
Est-ce que est-ce que votre profession
euh euh influe sur votre santé physique
et mentale ?
Sur Antoine ? Ouais.
Un peu quelque part surtoine. Ouais.
Ouais. Ça manifeste comment ?
Sans rentrer dans les détails ? Non,
mais je crois que tu fais aussi cette
profession parce que tu es
parce que c'est un sacerdoce, parce que
tu as des valeurs.
Ouais, voilà, c'est ça. C'est c'est des
trucs, c'est quand tu as quand tu es,
j'allais dire un peu révolté ou en
colère face à
un discours qui n'a aucun sens, qui est
complètement contradictoire, des gens
qui font n'importe quoi,
c'est ça être journaliste. Oui, je pense
que tu le fais pour ça parce que c'est
un état d'esprit. Vous avez fait vous
avez fait euh alors toi tu as fait un
tax tu as fait un tacle à valeur
actuelle. Ils sont journalistes aussi.
Oui, bien sûr. Mais non, mais le journal
de presse
non mais oui, mais bien sûr. Mais le
journalisme, c'est 15000 choses
différentes. Tu vois la personne qui va
faire euh son
Non, mais sa double page dans un journal
féminin, le meilleur le meilleur
maquillage waterproof pour aller à la
plage cet été. C'est parce que tu peux
pas comprendre ça de
Non mais je comprends qu'il y a un
intérêt et du coup cette personne elle a
une carte de presse et dans dans un
autre style quelqu'un qui va partir
pendant un mois au fin fond de la Syrie
pour faire un reportage sur les camps
dans lesquels se retrouvent les anciens
djihadistes et cetera. C'est pas du tout
le même genre de métier mais une carte
de presse aussi et les deux sont
valables. Après des motivations est-ce
qu'il y a la même déontologie dans les
deux ? Ça mais
la déontologie c'est complètement euh
enfin ouais me lance pas me lance pas si
si si si je te lance là-dessus le
conseil supérieur de la déontologie je
sais pas quoi de la proposition de
Cédrico.
Mais c'est mais c'est n'importe quoi.
C'est n'importe quoi. C'est ce que j'ai
c'est ce que j'ai écrit. Je me suis fait
allumer parce que j'ai écrit ça mais je
suis pas le seul. Tu
t' fait allumer par qui ? Je me suis
fait allumer par les gens qui euh qui
sont euh euh
par la profession,
par les gens dans la profession qui sont
pour ce conseil. Il y en a, on on
comprend bien que euh
il faut euh l'introspection dont on
parlait pour euh le le l'État euh ou les
entreprises euh c'est normal qu'il y en
ait aussi pour les journalistes. Les
journalistes peuvent pas faire n'importe
quoi, euh raconter n'importe quoi et euh
ou promouvoir telle ou telle idéologie
ou tel ou tel discours. Et voilà. Bon,
donc c'est normal que on puisse
réfléchir sur nous-même, sur notre
profession. En revanche, euh ce que je
disais, je suis pas le seul à avoir dit
que c'était une idioc parce que le
canard enchaîné qui s'y connaît un tout
petit peu en indépendance et euh et en
déontologie euh
a appelé ça une bouffonnerie avant que
ça arrive. Ils ont dit c'est une
bouffonnerie.
Pourquoi ? parce que il existe un droit
de la presse. Les les dérives les plus
importantes sont traité par une chambre
à Paris, la 17e chambre qui est
spécialisée dans ces délit. Les gens
vont consulter les décisions de la 17e
tellement c'est écrit avec bon voilà,
c'est sont des gens qui sont vraiment
des spécialistes. Euh
on n pas besoin d'un truc en plus.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer finalement ?
Les gens qui font des procès billons
vont continuer à faire des procès
billons devant la 17e ou ailleurs et en
plus vont saisir ce conseil en disant
"Oui, vous comprenez voilà ce
journaliste de toute façon c'est un
gauchiste ou ce journaliste c'est un
type d'extrême droite et donc il dit ça
parce que parce que et à la fin en fait
on va nous faire notre boulot
correctement mais en plus des éventuels
procès billon on va devoir passer du
temps à expliquer un conseil
que moi personnellement à qui je ne
reconnais aucune autorité, mais je vais
devoir répondre et dire "Oui, j'ai fait
mon travail correctement, voilà mes
preuves, blab blaba et cetera. J'ai pas
de temps à perdre pour ça, je sais ce
que je fais et moi ma déontologie en
interne, voilà, c'est carré, c'est j'ai
pas de souci, je sais où je vais, je
sais ce que je fais."
Euh donc j'ai j'ai pas du tout besoin
d'aller expliquer à des gens dont
peut-être la déontologie est un peu
parfois comme ça mais qui sont là parce
que on va distribuer des postes des
petites breloques, tu fais partie du
conseil de déontologie machin chose. Euh
non je je vois pas du tout d'intérêt de
ce trucl mais je dis le canard a appelé
ça une bouffonnerie continue à l'appeler
une bouffonnerie régulièrement je pense
que ils savent de quoi il par le CSA ?
Non, le CSA ça s'applique en fait euh à
la télé, donc moi ça me concerne pas
énormément. Donc je sais pas.
Mais comment dire ? Moi je pense que il
y a une il y a une vraie question qui
est euh comment rapprocher les
journalistes et les citoyens ? Euh ça
c'est une vraie question parceil
de merde. Mais il y en a aussi qui font
du très bon boulot. Donc faut
C'est pour ça que vous êtes là.
Ouais merci. Mais bon mais voilà mais la
question c'est comment ? C'est une des
professions les plus détestées de
France. Voilà.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? Ben justement
parce que elle est perçue comme ça Cour
d'Ivoire parce que je pense qu'on
confond journalisme de terrain et tous
les commentateurs euh ces grandes voix
et tout ça qui viennent.
C'est quoi les grandes voix ?
Mais c'est ce sont les éditocrates. Mais
regarde un truc euh un truc rigolo.
Un truc rigolo. Comment la presse a
traité les gilets jaunes au départ de
crise
? Voilà. Non mais c'est mais ça c'est
intéressant parce que tu tu as tu as des
trucs où je veux dire les les les
reporters de de BFM se sont fait
molester dans dans la rue.
Il a pas que
non
non il y a pas que mais je je donne cet
exemple là un exemple par
d'ailleurs inadmissible
ce qui est d'ailleurs inadmissible.
Oui c'est totalement inadmissible mais
je je vais t'expliquer pourquoi pourquoi
c'est peut-être complètement débile en
plus c'estàd que tu as des gens sur le
terrain des reporters sur le terrain qui
vont faire des images qui vont faire un
commentaire.
Ils envoient ces images à des gens qui
eux ne sont pas sur la manif, ne savent
pas ce qui s'est passé, ont une vision
qui est leur vision, on sait pas comment
c'est construit mais en tout cas ils
sont pas sur le terrain, il voit pas ce
qui se passe. Et une fois qu'ils
reçoivent ces images, ils les montent.
Donc il les coupent, ils les remettent
dans un sens qui colle avec leur vision
du truc. D'accord ? Et ils vont faire un
commentaire par-dessus. Le type qui va
faire le commentaire, si ça se trouve,
il a pas mis les pieds non plus sur la
manife. Donc si tu veux, le produit
final est peut-être inverse de ce que
les gens sur place ont envoyé. Puis il y
a les fameux bordeaux, le bandeau en
permanence avec la question, l'angle et
donc le bandeau, ça influe sur la
lecture de l'image. Voilà. Donc donc
peut-être que ces gens sont sont des
gens qui étaient sur place sur le
terrain sont critiqués à tort en fait.
On sait pas. Stéphanie.
Non mais c'est de toute façon
effectivement il y a plusieurs types de
journalistes
et c'est compliqué de aujourd'hui la
profession est très décriée parce que je
pense qu'il y a une perte de confiance
qui vient effectivement euh je pense de
des éditorialistes qui quelque part eux
ne sont pas sur les terrains. Le terrain
n'enquête pas et en fait comment ça se
passe ? Je pense enfin je connais pas
très bien le métier non plus mais a
priori enfin leur métier à eux a priori
bah c'est des repas des cocktails où on
se rend compte où on va essayer d'avoir
la bonne petite phrase du politique en
ce moment sous les projecteurs de savoir
qu'est-ce qui prévoit et cetera et je ne
dis pas que c'est pas une information
éventuellement qui peut être
intéressante parce que qui peut ne pas
être intéressante parce que l'air de
rien de savoir ce que bah quelque part
le gouvernement peaufine sans l'avoir
encore dévoilé ça peut être quand même
intéressant Mais le problème c'est que
on est tous humains et qu'à partir du
moment où on commence à copiner avec ces
gens-là, bah on copine. Donc du coup
du coup c'est compliqué ensuite de
garder, je pense une certaine distance
quand on enquête. C'est très compliqué
finalement de bah d'accepter des
déjeuners, des choses comme ça parce que
effectivement on est quand même tous
humains. C'est quand même aller c'est
quand même compliqué d'aller taper sur
quelqu'un avec qui on a éventuellement
pris un repas, pris un café et tout ça.
Et tout. Bah moi je pense qu'il faut
gard plaisir.
Moi je pense qu'il faut garder une
distance. Bah moi je suis pas
tu as un problème aussi avec les voilà
les les éditocrates.
Moi je les appelle aussi les
toutologues. Ils savent tout sur tout en
fait et donc on peut les interroger sur
absolument tout.
Ça pose un problème qu'on peut appliquer
à l'ensemble de Mais tu vois c'est c'est
un problème très complexe en fait dans
une dans une rédaction. Je parle de la
presse écrite dans une rédaction dans le
temps. Euh donc je t'ai dit moi il y a
il y a il y a 200 ans quand j'ai
commencé euh quand tu tu travaillais sur
un sujet et tu devenais expert du sujet
parce que tu le traitais pendant 10 ans
et voilà tu tu connaissais ton sujet
donc tu savais de quoi tu parlais.
Aujourd'hui c'est plus comme ça.
Pourquoi ? Parce que les gens ils vont
rester 1 an sur le sujet. Ils vont
rester 2 ans maximum. On va prendre
plein de petits jeunes qui sortent de
l'école parce que ça coûte moins cher.
Donc on va les mettre sur sur des sujets
compliqués. Ils sont pas formés pour ça.
Donc au bout d'un moment, qu'est-ce qui
se passe ? Ton toutologue ou ton type
qui sort de l'école et qui a qui a pas
eu qui a pas été formé ou personne ne
l'a pris en main dans la rédaction pour
le former et cetera, bah ces gens-là,
ils vont écrire quoi ? Ils vont ils vont
dire ou écrire des trucs qui sont pas
toujours justes. Donc de temps en temps,
il y a une grosse connerie. Et quand
quelqu'un est lecteur et que il connaît
son sujet et qu'il voit qu'il y a une
bêtise qui a été écrite, ben la
confiance baisse et le type se dit "Bon
bah si c'est tout comme ça dans tout le
journal he pourquoi je vais mettre 2 €
pour acheter un journal ou si ça se
trouve tout ce qu'il y a dedans est du
même ordre.
Et de qui sont ces gens pour venir
écrire sur ce sujet alors qu'il
visiblement ils n'y connaissent rien ?
C'est c'est dommage mais ça c'est tout
un ensemble économique qui fait que la
qualité des journaux baissent. On va
fermer des postes parce que tu as des
gens qui sont spécialistes
Ouais. Puis tu as des spécialistes des
Excels à qui on te demande de
rentabiliser une entreprise de presse.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Ils vont couper
des postes qui coûtent de l'argent et
qui pour eux voilà ça n'a pas de sens.
par exemple la DOC, donc les gens qui
s'occupent de la documentation, on va
les fermer parce de toute façon il y a
internet. Euh le correcteur parce que
pourquoi on aurait six correcteurs, on
en gardait que deux, mais le les deux
correcteurs, ils vont devoir se taper le
serveur web, tout ce qui est pas tout ce
qui passe sur le web, tout ce qui passe
sur le papier. Euh donc ils y arrivent
plus. Donc effectivement, tu as des des
fautes de français, des fautes
d'orthographe et cetera, la qualité
baisse et donc effectivement bah le le
la profession est décriée. Mais c'est
tout un ensemble en fait.
Stéphanie, tu veux rajouter un mot sur
ça ?
Pas spécialement. Non non.
Comment tuexpliques que la profession
n'ait pas vu Donald Trump émerger et se
fait réir ?
Alors là,
moi je trouve qu'on quand même ça se
sentait quand même. Non, c'était pas
Tu as euh je sais pas, tu as tu as quand
même un autre problème qu'on peut
reprocher, un autre truc qu'on peut
reprocher à la presse, c'est que euh on
va pas dire tous, une une grande partie
des journalistes est issue du du même
moule. C'est un peu les mêmes les mêmes
tranches en fait de la population. Ils
ont fait à peu près les mêmes études et
cetera. Donc c'est c'est de moins en
moins vrai. Mais accondu à la Ligue du
LOL.
Ouais. Alors la Ligue du LOL, c'est
encore un autre problème. Mais non, je
pense que c'est plutôt que en fait sont
des gens qui ont une un certain niveau
d'éducation, un certain niveau social
etime, ils s'estiment avec un niveau
d'éducation.
Ouais. Après bon voilà, mais si tu veux,
ils ont une analyse du monde qui est
voilà un peu pour tout le monde un peu
la même et et tout le monde va te dire
"Non mais Donald Trump c'est un clown,
c'est un guignol, il passera jamais."
Euh ben peut-être que si on avait été
demandé aux gens dans la rue plutôt que
euh à des politiques ou à des gens voilà
d'une même tranche sociale, si on a été
voir les gens qui votent vraiment,
peut-être qu'on l'aurait plus vu arriver
de même façon que aujourd'hui peut-être
il faut regarder en France que va-t-il
se passer à la prochaine élection ?
Est-ce que si on est comme dans les les
sphères macronistes, on pense qu'il y a
aucun souci, on va être élu et tout va
bien se passer parce que tout va bien et
que on est
on a raison dans ce qu'on fait et dans
nos dans nos réformes
ou est-ce que si on va voir les gens
dans la rue et on leur pose la question,
voilà, qu'est-ce qui va se passer la
prochaine élection ?
Monsieur Duplé, quelque chose à rajouter
? Non, non, non, parce que mais je
partage l'analyse d'Antoine, quoi.
C'est-à-dire qu'effectivement le euh il
faut sortir des de nos cercles de
confort, quoi. C'est-à-dire euh oser
aller voir euh des gens qu'on à qui on
donne pas forcément la parole. Le la
question c'est à qui on voilà à qui on
donne la parole. Et je crois qu'
journaliste, il faut qu'on fasse
attention à donner la parole à des gens
qui l'ont pas forcément. Et voilà. Donc
et je pense que ça rééquilibrerait un
peu certaines choses et certaines
perceptions de la société.
J' dire les derniers qui donnent la
parole un peu à tout le monde, c'est la
presse locale. J'allais dire la presse
locale, moi j'ai travaillé à West France
pendant 3 ans. Euh
qui d'ailleurs fait du boulot ?
Ah ça ils font un super boulot. C'est
c'est un journal local qui donne
vraiment la parole
aux gens. Voilà. Après, j'allais dire il
a comme tout le monde a des défauts, je
veux dire, il donne la parole à tout le
monde. Par contre, faire de
l'investigation à Westfance, j'en ai
fait un tout petit peu, c'est très
compliqué parce qu'il y a des telles
connexions avec les entreprises locales,
avec les politiques locaux que si on n'
pas un directeur départemental
qui a le courage de le faire. Ouais,
mais moi j'en ai eu un mais il y en a
des fois ils volent surtout pas.
Euh, il s'appelait euh Arnaud Bélier.
Voilà. Et donc lui, il a eu maintenant
il est dans d'autres sphères de
West-France, mais enfin voilà. Mais il a
pris du galon mais voilà et à l'époque
lui ça le dérangeait pas. C'està-dire
qu'il assumait mais ça veut dire qu'à un
moment on s'est fâché avec le
commissariat alors que pour nous c'était
une source mais on a eu d'autres sources
après hein parce que d'un côté on se
fâche avec des gens et puis de l'autre
côté on gagne des sources parce qu'il y
a des gens il nous il y a des gens ils
nous respectent quand on fait notre
travail. Voilà mais par contre tout ce
qui est comment dire donner la parole à
la base aller faire des portraits de
gens locaux qui sont extraordinaires ou
qui vivent quelque chose bon bah eux ils
le font parce que ils sont proches de la
population. Donc voilà, mais la entre la
presse nationale et la presse sur
locale, évidemment, on n'a pas la même
approche, on n' pas la même place
consacrée au local et la question c'est
vraiment rotisser le le le lien de
confiance. Stéphanie.
Non mais moi je suis assez d'accord sur
retisser le lien de confiance mais après
voilà, il y a
tout dépend de ce qu'on fait aussi,
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'est pas forcément
toujours sur le terrain non plus avec en
contact avec les gens qui par exemple là
mais c'est sûr que par exemple sur le
mouvement des gilets jaunes enfin d'en
parler depuis un plateau télé sans être
allé sur le terrain, c'est quand même
juste hallucinant. Et ça, je pense que
ça fait partie
euh de de ça qui de c de ce constat où
euh et bien il y a une perte de
confiance puisque il y a des gens
effectivement qui ont un avis sur tout
sans même être allé s'y frotter. Contact
direct.
Bah oui, forcément. Donc voilà. Mais moi
je pense que voilà un journaliste quand
je dis on fait de l'enquête, on fait en
fait finalement normalement quel que
soit notre sujet c'est on doit aller se
confronter aux choses. On peut pas juste
lire des livres et lire tous nos en fait
lire tous nos confrères en fait c'est ça
se relire se relire et après
recommencer. Donc maintenant il faut
aller au contact du terrain voir
vraiment enquêter sur son sujet et
enquêter quand je dis enquêter ça peut
être juste un coup de fil.
Vous avez fait de l'infiltration ou des
choses comme ça ? Oui. Bou quoi ? Très
peu. Ouais, très peu
très peu.
Tu as pas besoin de cacher le fait que
tu es que tu es journaliste pour pour
aller au contact des gens et d'ailleurs
enfin
de toute façon tu es cramé toi.
Ouais, bon on est Oui, bien sûr. Non
mais bien sûr. Non mais moi par exemple,
je suis allé sur le stand à Milipol sur
le stand d'Amésis. Euh je les avais
jamais rencontré, je les avais jamais
vu. Ah bah te connaissais hein.
Ah bah voilà, je suis arrivé. Ah bonjour
monsieur Champagne. Bon voilà, je suis
cramé. Non mais ce que je veux dire, je
vais dans le sens de ce que dit
Stéphanie, c'est quoi ton pseudo
quitz-toi
le je vais dans le sens de ce que dit
Stéphanie. Moi, je suis allé et ça va
dans l'histoire de la perception de la
presse par le public. Je j'ai suivi à
peu près toutes les manifes l'année
dernière, tous les samedis avec mon
appareil photo, ma caméra, mon machin et
cetera pour pour être au contact de ce
mouvement social que le le regard que je
porte sur le mouvement, peu importe,
mais si je vais pas dessus pour voir
comment ça se passe, comment je pourrais
en parler.
Et dedans
hein ?
Dedans, c'est pas mieux. Dedans ?
Dedans.
Dans le mouvement ?
Dans le mouvement. Non non, je suis dans
les manifes entre les manifestants et la
police. Donc voilà, tu vois, il y a les
LBD qui fuse.
Voilà, c'est ça. Et euh et du coup donc
je je je fais ces manifes, je rentre et
quand je rentre le soir,
je reprends ma voiture et je mets la
radio. Et quand j'écoute le commentaire
sur France info que c'est bon voilà,
c'est la radio hein.
Et je me dis "Mais on n'a pas euh vécu
la même manif, c'est pas possible, on
n'est pas allé au même endroit." Et du
coup, je me mets à la place des gens qui
se sont pris euh des gaz dans la
tronche, des LBD dans la tête, dans
l'œil et cetera. Ils se sont fait mais
mais matraquer. Enfin, c'est infernal
quand tu es dessus et que tu vois ce qui
se passe et tu te dis "Mais ces gens-là
quand ils entendent ça à la radio ou à
la télé mais ils doivent être en colère.
Ils doivent être super énervés de voir
queon raconte pas ce qui ce qui leur est
vraiment arrivé."
euh les journées ça sein de la
population parce que du coup on y va pas
non plus. Donc
colère mon la colère monte.
C'est on peut pas faire baisser la la
pression comme ça, c'est pas possible.
Donc effectivement les gens veulent au
journaliste, c'est dommage
et surtout qu'il y a énormément de
journalistes indépendants sur les
manifes qui font leur boulot
correctement. qui sont coffrés, qui
coffr der encore
qui qui prennent des coups de LBD dans
la tronche, enfin des tirs de LBD dans
la tronche. Enfin, il y a il y a tout eu
hein.
Mais et ce qu'il faut voir aussi c'est
par rapport au terrain, le problème
aussi c'est que les journaux pour des
questions financières resteignent de
plus en plus le nombre de jours de
reportage.
Moi récemment, j'ai fait une enquête là
qui doit paraître dans l'ACro hebbdo sur
les décharges illégales. J'ai dit donc
dans le sud de la France, voilà donc
j'ai dit je vais avoir besoin de 15
jours à 3 semaines sur place. Réponse de
la rédactrice en chef. Si tu as besoin
de 15 jours, tu prends 15 jours. Si tu
as besoin de 3 semaines, tu prends 3
semaines. Ça, il y a honnêtement
longtemps que j'ai pas eu une réponse
pareille. Voilà. Et j'espère que ça va
durer. Donc le journal, il dit bah s'il
faut parce que il faut ça après il faut
bosser. C'estàdire que c'est préparé.
Moi derrière, je peux lui dire, j'ai
rencontré, j'ai travaillé quasiment tous
les jours sauf un dimanche. J'ai passé
presque 2 semaines et demi, voilà sur le
terrain.
B voilà. Bon après, il faut travailler,
il faut être sérieux et il faut le
rendre des comptes. Mais mais j'is dire
que il faut qu'on ait le temps de de
faire de rencontrer les gens,
d'investiguer, de voilà. Et ça, on l'a
de moins en moins. On nous dit "Ah bah
euh l'article va faire temps." Bon bah
c'est temps de jour parce que il faut il
y a un ratio entre la taille de
l'article des fois et le et souvent et
la taille de l'article et le coût. Donc
mais le problème c'est que si on va
faire une interview, on peut on peut
noircir une page en 2h ou 3h de
rencontre et noircir une page. Si on
fait la même page et qu'on fait de
l'investigation, on peut mettre 5 jours,
une semaine pour arriver à écrire une
page.
On arrive à à la fin de notre interview
et j'aimerais un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Alors, on va commencer par Stéphanie.
Faites autre chose. Non.
De quoi ? De journalistes ou les jeunes
des ration ?
Non mais euh
mais si
mais si un peu euh un peu. Non non mais
je sais moi mes enfants en tout cas euh
si
moi je veux faire journaliste.
Faire journaliste euh ouais je suis pas
je suis pas bien confiante. Je trouve
que c'est un métier quand même un peu
difficile euh on l'a dit euh pas
tellement dans l'exercice. Enfin après
voilà
dans l'exercice moi je pense qu'il y a
un état d'esprit qu'on a ou qu'on a pas.
Alors euh voilà, donc euh le
journalisme, on a presque pas besoin
d'aller à l'école, quoi. Presque parce
que quand même, il faut savoir un tout
petit peu écrire. Mais euh mais je sais
pas, les jeunes générations, moi je
trouve que mon métier est quand même
passionnant, mais c'est sûr que c'est
sûr que s'ils veulent très bien gagner
leur vie, avoir
voilà une
ne pas avoir peur du chômage et cetera,
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué.
Antoine
ou
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Ben pareil pareil, qu'est-ce que tu veux
que je te dise ? C'est c'est un très
beau métier. C'est souvent très
gratifiant.
Mais mais faites-le pas.
Non, c'est pas Non, c'est pas le faites
pas. C'est c'est sûr que si tu cherches
à avoir un certain confort de vie et et
une paix intérieure,
tu peux venir ce soir prendre ta douche
si tu veux.
Tu peux faire Ouais. Bah ouais, ça j'ai
bien noté. Je je vais passer tous les
jours maintenant. Ouais. Non non, c'est
voilà, il y a il y a des trucs, il faut
il y a des trucs plus calmes quoi.
Bah moi, il y a deux choses. Moi, je
dirais par rapport déjà aux jeunes
génération plus large que le
journalisme, moi je dirais il faut pas
penser que l'information elle est
gratuite.
Je veux dire ne il faut pas consommer de
l'info uniquement en allant se balader à
droite à droite. Ah bah c'est payant.
Bon bah si c'est payant, je passe à
autre chose.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Nous c'est
gratuit mais en fait c'est pas gratuit.
C'est notre communauté qui paye pour les
autres qui n'ont pas de pognon.
Exctement. Euh
euh là, nous le on est en train de
bosser sur un documentaire hardcore,
c'est pour ça que j'ai une tête un peu
fatiguée. Euh mais c'est la communauté
qui tous les mois nous finance, qui paye
les salaires, qui paye l'électricité,
qui paye les caméras et j'en passe. Fait
parenthèse fermée. Donc
ouais voilà. Et moi je dis l'information
effectivement il y a même si elle
apparaît gratuite comme tu dis dans le
cas de Syerview, elle apparaît gratuite
mais elle l'est pas et voilà et il faut
pas croire parce que si plus c'est
gratuit c'estàd qu'à un moment c'est
vous le client c'estàd que derrière il y
a des pubs, il y a des biaiss. C'estàd
que si l'information est gratuite on
peut se dire qu'il y a des biais dans ce
qu'on va lire. Voilà c'està dire que ça
va dépendre de la pub, ça va dépendre
d'un milliardaire qui aura ses
orientations et qui va les imposer au
journal. Voilà. Donc un moment, je dire
il faut il faut voir il faut choisir ce
qu'on lit et s'abonner payer à certains
endroits pour avoir une une information
de qualité. Voilà. Après moi je pense
que le journalisme honnêtement c'est
nécessaire vraiment jeis dire un
nécessaire et c'est un c'est un métier
passionnant. Bon après il y a
difficultés qu'on a dit mais c'est je
crois que c'est un métier passionnant et
je crois que c'est absolument nécessaire
si on est curieux et qu'on veut essayer
de décrypter le monde parce qu'on est
dans des complexités immenses en
permanence. Bon, on a je dire on arrive
pas forcément à grand-chose, mais cette
complexité-là, il faut aider à la
décrypter. Et euh sinon, on se fait
balader, c'est le ro c'est le royaume
des fake news, c'est celui qui a le plus
d'argent euh qui va faire imposer sa
vérité, ça va être les lobbyes. Enfin,
là voilà, on travaille sur ces
questions-là de lobbing. Si on va avoir
de l'accès à un moment, il faut pouvoir
qu'il y ait des gens le plus
indépendants possible qui puissent
mettre les cartes sur la table, quoi.
Stéphanie, le mot de la fin
par rapport aux jeunes générations.
Ouais. Ouais.
Mais non, mais allez voir notre
documentaire. vraiment sur reflet.com
mais reflet.info
désolé
reflet.infoadisiac
Caradisia méap reflet avec au pluriel.
Voilà et euh j'espère bientôt sur
interview. Je demande à la communauté,
ils sont en train de délibérer là.
Madames et messieurs, merci.
Merci.
[Musique]